Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Ich bin ein Kumpel von Menschen, die sich in der Welt verbreiten.
Die Leute, die hier mitmachen, machen dem Namen diesmal also wirklich alle Ehre. Das war glaube ich die am kürzsten vorbereiteten Sendung, die ich jemals gefahren habe. Ich hatte nämlich ungefähr zwei Minuten. Aber jetzt sind sie alle im Studio. Skusi, Konstanze Kurz und Frank Krieger. Hallo. Vom Chaos Computer Club. Und heute quasi die Sendungsankündigung ist ein Wust von Fremdworten. Wir haben ein Nichtanlassungsgesetz. Wir haben ein ACTA. Wir haben eine Zugangsersperrung. Wir haben eine Censilia. Habe ich noch was vergessen?
Ich habe in den Eindruck, dass der Moderator heute überhaupt nicht vorbereitet ist. Geht euch das genauso?
Ich wollte euch lediglich einen leichten Einstieg erlauben, damit ihr mal erklären könnt, worum es heute eigentlich geht.
Ja, worüber wir also reden wollen, sind die sogenannten Zugangssperren oder Netzsperren oder auch manchen nennen sie Pseudo-Sperren. Und zwar nicht nur auf deutscher Ebene, wo wir ja das Gesetz haben, streiten wir ja schon ein ganzes Jahr, sondern eben vor allen Dingen auch über die neue Initiative aus Brüssel von der neuen EU-Kommissarin, die diesen schönen Namen Censilia Malmström erhalten hat, in Anlehnung an das englische Wort für Zensur, Sensor-Chip. Und wir wollen noch ein bisschen reden über ACTA, die Geheimverhandlung zur sogenannten Pirateriebekämpfung und auch gleichzeitig noch über den Jugendmedienstaatsvertrag, denn wir glauben, dass all diesen Konzepten einfach eine ähnliche Denke zugrunde liegt, nämlich dass sie eine Regulierung des Internets mit technisch ziemlich, ja nicht wirklich adäquaten Mitteln haben und vor allen Dingen, wenn man ein bisschen darüber reden wird, wo dahinter steckt.
Also quasi der Grundansatz ist, wir können das Internet kontrollieren. Wir brauchen nur das richtige Gesetz dafür.
Na, nicht nur eingesetzter, sondern bündelangesetzter. Für uns stellt sich es mehr und mehr so dar, als wäre der grundlegende Ansatz zu sagen, wir müssen dieses Internet irgendwie unter Kontrolle bringen. Die Technologie dafür, so nehmen die zumindest offenbar an, existiere und da müssen wir das jetzt mal machen. Und da wollen wir heute darüber reden, wie funktioniert die Technologie tatsächlich, auch von Netzsperren und ähnlichen Dingen und welche Möglichkeiten hat man, drumherum zu kommen und ja, wollen wir auch ein bisschen mit den Hörern drüber reden.
Wait, also da ist ja schon der erste Mal, wie ACTA, müssen wir nochmal genau erklären, was das ist, ist ja eine schöne Abkürzung. Ich würde aber gerne mit Netzsperren anfangen, weil da mag vielleicht dem einen oder anderen vor dem neuartigen Grundfunkempfangsgerät so eine Art Deja-Vie aufkommen. Das hatten wir doch gerade alles. Wir hatten im letzten Jahr irgendwie die Zensursula-Dabatte, wo dann langwierig erklärt wurde, okay, das ist halt Unsinn, das funktioniert so nicht, löschen ist viel besser. Selbst die neue Bundesregierung hat sich irgendwann dazu durchgerungen, okay, wir lassen das Gesetz unterzeichnen, aber wir brauchen es eigentlich wirklich nicht. Wieso geht jetzt alles nochmal von vorne los?
Also das ist eigentlich so, dass aus Brüssel die Initiative, die jetzt von der EU kommensjahren kommt, eigentlich auch schon einen langen Vorlauf hat, nämlich auch schon ein Jahr, nur dass es jetzt gerade wieder hochköche, da sie das einfach jetzt öffentlich gemacht hat und halb Europa darüber debattiert. Das heißt eigentlich ist die Initiative, kann man sagen, zeitgleich gestartet.
Ja, hallo, hier ist der Scusi. Meine Theorie ist ja ganz einfach, dass Deutschland eigentlich der Testfall oder das Zugpferd für die EU-Ankündigung werden sollte und für diese Sperren, die jetzt auf EU-Ebene kommen. Leider hat es nicht ganz geklappt, jetzt kommt es halt dann nochmal auf EU-Ebene, aber wahrscheinlich, vermutlich hätte das andersrum laufen sollen. Deutschland hätte schon mal vorpreschen sollen, unter van der Leyen Regie und dann wäre der Rest Europas jetzt nachgezogen. Das in Deutschland hat leider nicht geklappt aus der Sicht.
Und die Frage stellt sich für uns also, wie können wir vielleicht jetzt auf der europäischen Ebene genauso erfolgreich gegen diese unsinnigen Sperren vorgehen, wie wir es in Deutschland geschafft haben?
Habe ich einen schönen Tweet heute zugelesen, da meinte jemand, oh mein Gott, fünf Jahre dagegen agitieren, das kann man noch niemals durchhalten. Ich meine, also in der Tat, wir haben jetzt irgendwie, eigentlich wollen wir alle das Gefühl, okay, jetzt hat irgendwie die Geschichte ein Ende, der Protest hat vielleicht sogar was geholfen und jetzt noch mal und das Ganze über mehrere Jahre. Wie soll denn das gehen?
Und auf Englisch.
Und auf Englisch. Also die, gut, also diese Geschichte mit der EU, da werden wir uns wohl irgendwie daran gewöhnen müssen, dass wir solche Kampagnen möglicherweise nicht nur einmal führen müssen, sondern mehrfach.
Es ist auch so, dass sich im Prinzip jetzt am Anfang schon zeigt, dass die ernste Debatte in Deutschland und die ziemlich vielen zusammengetragenen und auch sehr sachlichen Argumente jetzt auch übernommen werden. Also wir sehen, dass die Sachen, die bisher übersetzt wurden, auch sehr häufig zugegriffen werden. Also da bildet sich schon anderswo eine Bewegung. Und wenn man mal den Hashtag Censilia bei Twitter klickt, dann stellt man fest, das ist in allen Sprachen mittlerweile. Also es geht schon los.
Es ist also nicht nur so, dass die Unionspolitiker, die sowieso eigentlich diese ganze Netzsperren-Sache eine gute Idee fanden, jetzt sagen, ja stimmt, eigentlich jetzt wo sie in der EU sagen, könnte man doch mal probieren. Es ist auch so, dass die Gegner quasi nach Deutschland gucken und sagen, naja, da gab's ja schon mal ein paar Argumente gegen und sich quasi von euch den Ratschlag holen. Oder von den Akkordschristen, was es da alles noch gibt.
Da ist ja eine ganze Menge Arbeit passiert auch schriftlich, die halt übersetzt wird. Also gerade findet das hektisch übersetzend alle EU-Sprachen statt.
Na das heißt also an dieser Stelle auch Aufruf an die Hörer. Welche Sprachen braucht ihr noch?
Ach naja, eigentlich muss ich sagen, jetzt sind von den sachlichen Argumentationen her schon vieles in den Wickeys übersetzt worden. Wir stellen gerade fest, dass vor allen Dingen der MoGES-Verein jetzt sehr viele Sprachen hat. Also ich glaube, die haben jetzt auch Polnisch. Also es ist nicht mehr so die Standardsprachen wie Englisch und Französisch, sondern eben ich glaube acht oder neun Sprachen sind da schon.
Ja, also die interessante Geschichte ist, dass die Debatten in den einzelnen Staaten teilweise auch schon vorher begonnen haben, zum Beispiel Polen. Da ist parallel eigentlich die Entwicklung, die in Deutschland passiert ist, da auch nochmal passiert, ohne dass hier jemand so richtig toll mitbekommen hat.
Aber die Vernetzung passiert jetzt.
Genau, die Vernetzung passiert jetzt halt eben dadurch, dass wir gezwungen sind, auf EU-Ebene anzugehen, wird diese Debatte denke ich mal so die erste, wo es tatsächlich eine wirklich EU-weite Koordination der Aktivisten gibt.
Es ist ja auch so, dass eigentlich, wenn man die, gerade den Artikel, den die EU-Kommissarin über die Deutsche Frankfurter Allgemeine Zeitung veröffentlicht hat, wo sie begründet, warum wir diese Netzsperren brauchen, das ist dieselbe, also wirklich haargenau dieselbe Argumentation, die wir von unserer ehemaligen Familienministerin kennen. Erklär noch mal kurz. Sie hat im Prinzip argumentiert, dass die Darstellung von Kindesmissbrauch, von der Meinungsfreiheit nicht gedeckt sei, das natürlich was, was wir niemals behauptet hätten. Also sie kommt mit den alten Argumenten, ja, dass zwar vielleicht nicht immer sinnvoll ist, aber eben notwendig sei diese Sperren, da man ja angeblich nicht löschen könne. Also die Argumentation kennen wir halt schon.
Okay, ich muss an dieser Stelle mal einwerfen, ihr bemerkt, die Diskussion ist tatsächlich schon ein bisschen älter, wird quasi nochmal wieder aufgeholt. Trotzdem, wenn ihr jetzt gerade auf dem Rad sitzen denkt, okay, ich hab's nicht ganz genau verstanden, das ist kein Problem, denn dafür gibt es eine Telefonnummer. Die ihr natürlich auch wählen könnt, wenn ihr eure Meinung gründet wollen wollt, weil ihr es entweder alles total fürchterlich findet oder denkt, ja genau, wir brauchen jetzt Bern nicht nur Deutschland, sondern EU weit.
Wir haben nämlich aber auch noch ein paar mehr Fragen. Also es ist nicht nur so, dass ihr eure Meinung sagen sollt, sondern wir wollen vor allen Dingen ein paar Sachen von euch wissen. Und einer ist, wie umgeht ihr diese Sperren, was ist da eure Idee, wie währt ihr euch technisch und wie ist vielleicht eure Idee, wie man diesen ganzen Protest europäisieren kann? Und glaubt ihr, dass das funktionieren wird, so gut wie das in Deutschland funktioniert hat? Da würden wir schon gerne mit euch debattieren.
Also, habt ihr gehört, die Frage ist, wenn Netzperren kommen, macht ihr was dagegen und wenn ja, was? Und wenn ihr dagegen vorgehen wollt, wie soll das passieren, vor allen Dingen, wie soll es so passieren, dass die Leute in anderen Ländern auch mitkriegen?
Und möglichst auch mitmachen und mithelfen. Auch noch. Übersetzen und den Protest bei sich zu Hause auf die Straße tragen.
Genau.
Okay, das hört sich ein bisschen wie geistige Brandstiftung an, was sie hier macht.
Wir machen Revolutionen, haben wir doch schon seit Jahren. Das ist nur eine leise Revolution.
Diese Geschichte, dass wir die Sachen und die Debatten, die wir hier schon mal geführt haben über den internationalen Umweg wiederbekommen, kennen wir schon seit einer Weile. Bei der Biometrie war es ja so.
Vorratzeiten Speichungen.
Vorratzeiten Speichungen und ähnliche Dinge. Also das sind halt einfach Sachen, die in Deutschland, wo wir dachten, das ist jetzt schon einmal erledigt, kommt dann halt immer noch mal über den internationalen Umweg. In einer dieser Geschichten ist das so ein ACTA-Abkommen. Da sollten wir vielleicht auch noch mal kurz erklären, was das ist.
Also warte halt, bevor wir das machen, haben wir schon den ersten zu den Netzsperren. Den nehmen wir gleich noch rein, bevor wir zur ACTA übergehen. Janik ist das.
Ich wollte ein bisschen was zum Thema Netzsperren umgehen sagen. Und zwar irgendwie, ich finde es total sinnlos, erstmal hier mit, hier was Zensursula, sage ich mal, vorhatte. Also ich finde auch dafür Löschen statt Sperren. Weil Sperren kann man ja mit Diensten zum Beispiel wie OpenDNS total leicht umgehen, sprich wenn ich jetzt hier irgendeinen Provider habe, der dann die Kinder vorne auf die Blacklist sozusagen packt, kann ich ja einfach OpenDNS benutzen. Da läuft ja nicht, da ist ja nicht diese Blacklist vorhanden und da kann ich mir Sachen dann beispielsweise einfach weiter angucken.
Was du natürlich hoffentlich nicht würdest.
Nein, nein, das war gerade nur ein Beispiel.
Janik, ganz kurze Frage an dich. Es ist ja oft so, wenn ich sage, Chaos Radio kommt wieder, dann so, ja, es versteht doch kein Mensch. Schön, dass denn ein 14-jähriger Hörer aus Langwitz anruft und sagt, ja, DNS-Sperre, Blacklist, OpenDNS. Wie würdest du es jemand erklären, der keinen Plan davon hat?
Was ich euch gerade erzählt habe?
Genau.
Okay, also dann gibt es ja auch noch diese Erklärung mit, was DNS ist. Also ich sage es mal ganz einfach, so erkläre ich es auch immer meinen Freunden, die es nicht verstehen. Jetzt möchte ich mich jetzt bei Provider XY und wenn ich jetzt eingebe Google.de steckt dahinter eine Nummer sozusagen und wenn ich jetzt auf www.kinder-porno.de gehe, erkennt mein Provider, da wir auf die und die Seite gehen, dann schicken wir nicht auf die Nummer, sprich zu dem Computer, wo das alles ist, zu dem Server, sondern wir zeigen ihm mein Stoppschild. Ich kann jetzt aber einen anderen Dienst benutzen, der diese Adresse wie google.de auflöst, in diese Nummer, da benutze ich einfach so etwas wie OpenDNS und der leitet mich dann zu dieser Nummer weiter und da gibt es dann nicht diese Blacklist, wo dann irgendwie ein Stoppschild kommt, wenn ich dann auf www.kinder-porno.de gehe und da wird es dann nicht funktionieren, dass dann das Stoppschild da kommt.
Ok, das hast du super erklärt, aber die nächste Frage ist natürlich, warum zur Hölle willst du auf www.kinder-porno.de gehen?
Das war ein Beispiel.
Ja, ich finde, du hast das ziemlich gut beschrieben. Kannst du dir denn jetzt vorstellen, warum dann irgendwie der durchschnittliche Politiker nicht so peilt?
Naja, also irgendwie, ich weiß auch nicht, wann hat hier Ursula von der Leyen es eigentlich damals gemacht? Im November?
Ne, ein bisschen früher, nach vor der Wahl.
Also die erste Ankündigung war Ende November 2008, war die erste Ankündigung von ihrem Vorhaben in der Leipziger Volkszeitung, glaube ich.
Na gut, aber wir haben natürlich darüber gestritten eigentlich im Frühjahr, Sommer und dann direkt bis zur Wahl.
Ja, aber ich finde irgendwie, wenn jetzt irgendwie Politiker kommen, macht einen auf ganz modern so auf, ich habe Ahnung vom PC und sagt, Kinderpornos sollten geschwert werden, dass er keine rauf. So ist das voll die gute Idee, endlich wird mal sowas kriminelles hier, kann man sich nicht mehr angucken. Ist doch voll die gute Idee. Stimmen natürlich alle dafür, finden alle gut, aber im Endeffekt haben die Politiker gar keine Ahnung. Ich wette, es hat hier irgendein Freund von ihr erzählt, ja, sagt das und das, dann sehen dich bestimmt alle.
Das ist ja mal eine Theorie.
Ja, ich glaube, das finde ich jetzt nicht so unplausibel. Janik, auf jeden Fall vielen Dank schon mal und gute Erklärung, am besten aufschreiben, rumschicken. Müssen noch mehr Leute wissen.
Kann ich dann auf meine Seite stellen?
Genau, mach das. So, jetzt aber, also auch, ihr habt es bestimmt schon 3000 Mal erklärt, aber natürlich ist die Frage noch, dass Sie sagen, okay, wir wissen jetzt, wie wir da rankommen an die Seiten, die sperren, aber warum will man die denn überhaupt umgehen?
Also es gibt natürlich ein ganzes Bündel an Argumenten. Das erste ist natürlich, was jetzt oft als allererstes genannt wird, ist die Tatsache, dass sie technisch eben nicht wirksam sind, sondern eben, wie uns der gerade Janik erklärt hat, super einfach in wenigen Sekunden zu umgehen sind. Und das geht ja eben gerade nicht um Leute wie uns oder Janik oder dich, sondern geht natürlich um Pädophile, die gezielt danach suchen und die werden wenige Sekunden brauchen, um diese wirkungslose Stop-Schild zu umgehen. Aber das ist gar nicht mal der Kern der Argumentation, wenn man es jetzt mal betrachtet inhaltlich. Es geht vor allen Dingen auch um die Frage, ob es kontraproduktive Wirkung hat, diese Zugangserschwerungsgesetz und diese Sperren. Und da muss die Antwort wohl deutlich Ja sein. Dann wird es so eine geheime Sperrliste vom BKA mal geben. Dann wird sie wie alle anderen Sperrlisten natürlich auch kursieren. Und damit hat der geneigte Pädophile natürlich wie eine Art Telefonbuch. Und insofern ist es nicht mal nur nicht wirkungsvoll, sondern ist auch kontraproduktiv.
Eine Einkaufsliste für Kinderpornofreunde, das ist total super. Wir haben jetzt, bevor wir zu ACTA kommen, noch den Kai.
Ja, ich wollte vielleicht noch zwei Worte dazu verlieren, wie man andere Leute in Europa aktivieren kann. Ich denke, die beste Chance ist, dass man über auch die technisch versierten Leute geht. Und da viele von uns und wahrscheinlich auch von euren Hörern ja irgendwie in Software-Projekten drin sind, die grenzübergreifend ja sogar weltweit Leute haben, dann denke ich, ist vielleicht das Beste, dass man da über einen IRC oder sonst wo einfach mal die Leute anspricht. Ja, habt ihr schon davon gehört, habe ich jetzt auch schon zwei, drei Mal gemacht. Ich denke, das Hauptproblem ist eigentlich die Apartheit von all den anderen. Also zu sagen, ja, aber ich kann ja nichts machen oder ich habe keine Zeit oder so. Aber wenn man einmal da drüber ist, dann merkt man auch, dann geht auch bei denen was los. Dann gehen die mal im Freundeskreis rum, kommen auch wieder und sagen, ja, aber der hat gesagt das und das und dann kann man den wieder mit neuen Argumenten aufmunizieren. Und dann gehen sie auch selber los, sind ja im Endeffekt auch alles Hacker im Sinne des DCCR.
Ja, okay, du glaubst, dass das... Die Idee ist gut. Ich finde die auch ziemlich gut, aber das einzige Problem dabei ist, das hat bei uns gut funktioniert und ich glaube auch, dass die gesamten Leute, die ein bisschen Ahnung vom Netz haben, irgendwie sehr schnell gepeilt haben, was das für ein Unsinn ist. Aber der Problem ist, die Entscheider gehören meistens halt nicht zu so Open Source Projekten. Wie kriegt man es von da wieder raus?
Aber das ist ja dann so wie in Deutschland, also das hängt dann, also das ging ja in Deutschland auch von uns, sage ich mal, ab, die technisch basiert sind. Wir haben einfach so lange Randale gemacht, erst online und dann hat es auch langsam offline gedämmert, bis man es nicht mehr ignorieren konnte.
Wir haben keine Randale gemacht, wir haben sie mit sachlichen Argumenten gekriegt. Das ist doch das Schöne, oder?
Also könnten wir es vielleicht aus dem Begriff sachliche Randale einigen?
Aus Sicht der Befürworter machen wir Randale. Weil da sind die so nicht gewohnt. Also das letzte Mal so richtig dicke Demonstrationen und so online wie offline, da kann man in Deutschland mal gucken. Wir kriegen jetzt seit Jahren die Freiheit statt Angst hin. Und das ist einfach gigantisch.
Aber dein Plan ist im Wesentlichen sozusagen die gut vernetzte europäische Tech-Community wird über ihre privaten Kleideprogrammierprojekte sozusagen revolutionär in die anderen Länder sickern lassen. Das ist eine gute Idee. Ich finde es erstmal nicht schlecht.
Ja, ich hoffe einfach, die verstehen das erstmal und die finden dann für ihr Land die jeweils besseren Beispiele, als wenn ich jetzt sage, ja, bei uns ist das so. Das sieht man auch jetzt in dem Blog von der Frau Malmström, da haben sich jetzt hauptsächlich Deutsche gemeldet. Mir scheint, das fängt schon an, 90% Deutsche und die bringen halt lauter Beispiele mit in Germany. Da kann die Frau sagen, na gut, juckt mich nicht die Bohnen.
Okay, also wenn ihr schon mal dabei seid, eine ordentlich funktionierende Open Source Office Suite für den Mac zu programmieren, wäre ich euch erstens sehr dankbar. Und zweitens könntet ihr dann gleich mal darüber sprechen, wie das aussieht mit dem Netzsperren-Protest.
Bitte, gerne.
So, also Netzsperren sind die Leute anscheinend doch im Thema. Es ist weit verbreitet und es besteht auch Bedarf. Jetzt haben wir das nächste, was an den Start geht, ACTA. Jetzt hätte ich gerne erst mal das ausgesprochen. Ich habe es vorhin versucht zu erinnern. Ich habe es mir missglückt. Weiß einer, was das heißt?
Das heißt Anti-Trade-Counterfeining-Agreement. Also es geht um die Anti-Piraterie.
Also Anti-Counterfeining-Trade-Agreement.
Hab ich Trade vergessen?
Du hast Anti-Trade gesagt, was auch ziemlich lustig ist.
Ja, das liegt daran, dass ich der einzige, der hier nicht auf dem Display starte, ja, wenn ich mich mal anmerke. Ja, sag es mal nochmal, damit es nicht zügig ist.
Das ist Anti-Counterfeiting-Trade-Agreement.
Genau.
So, was ist das?
Also das ist im Prinzip ein internationales Abkommen, also geht über die EU hinaus und dabei geht es zunächst um wirtschaftliche Interessen. Das heißt im Wesentlichen nicht nur über wirtschaftliche Fragen, sondern tatsächlich über Produkt, Piraterie und so weiter. Das heißt, es wird ein Abkommen, was derzeit geheim verhandelt wird, wo sich diese Staaten, die dort mitverhandeln, auf bestimmte Regeln und auch Sanktionen gegenüber zum Beispiel die Anbieter, aber auch gegen die einzelnen Benutzer einigen wollen. Das heißt, in all diesen Ländern sollen bestimmte Standards gelten.
Wobei, was man dazu sagen muss, ist, dass es halt so lange, also 2006 oder so, haben die angefangen zu verhandeln, das flog halt ziemlich lange unter dem Radar. Markus will nicht auf seinem Display starren, weil nach außen hinsieht, erst mal so aus, als würde da primär um gefälschte Gucci-Handtaschen und so eine Sache gehen, um geistiges Eigentum in Produktform. Und dann erst nach und nach stellt er sich raus, dass es halt dabei auch sehr wohl um Fallscheren geht, um Privatgruppie geht, um das Recht halt einen Internetanschluss zu besitzen, weil zum Beispiel einer der Dinge, die halt in den mittlerweile gelegten, aus den geheimen Verhandlungen rausgelegten Entwürfen, stehen halt solche Sachen drinnen, wie dass Internetprovider nur dann davon ausgenommen sind, dass sie mithaften für Fallscheren, was über sie passiert, wenn sie ein Mechanismus haben, Benutzer vom Netz abzuklemmen, wenn sich da einer von den Konten Mafia-Leuten drüber beschwert, also die wollen es so bauen, dass die Unterzeichnerstaaten Netzsperren verpflichtend in ihre Gesetze aufnehmen müssen, wenn sie Bestandteil dieses Abkommens sein sollen.
Und dass eben die Provider haften, das ist der zweite Punkt.
Also Netzsperren in dem Censiliasinn oder im Sinne von dieses Three-Strikes, was es auch in Frankreich gibt? Wenn du dreimal verdächtigerweise erwischt wurdest, wie du eine fremde Datei, die dir gar nicht gehört tauschst, dann wirst du einfach abgeklemmt. Für immer?
Nee, also in Frankreich ist es so, dass es eine gewisse Frist gibt, aber zunächst mal, ich glaube das ist seit zwölf Monaten, da bin ich jetzt gerade nicht sicher.
Also da sind halt noch andere Grauslichkeiten drin, zum Beispiel, dass die Staaten eigentlich vereinbaren wollten, dass digitale Datenträger und Computer an den Grenzen durchsucht werden dürfen, um festzustellen, ob sich darauf illegal getauschte Dateien befinden. Das widerspricht halt so in einigen Staaten schon der Verfassung.
Bevor wir darauf eingehen, dass es auch eine Verfassungsscheine ist, wie ist das denn überhaupt, also gibt es ja schon eine praktische Anwendung, weil ich habe ja mit der Vorgängeremodertoren Piranha, DJ, hat irgendwie 90 GB Musik auf ihrer Festplatte zum Auflegen. Wie soll die denn an der Grenze überhaupt nachweisen, dass es sozusagen völlig unrealistisch geht?
Das ganze Ding geht halt primum Einschüchterung, das ist vollkommen klar.
Naja, das betrifft ja auch jedes Stück Software. An der Grenze hast du natürlich auch deine Lizenzen nicht dabei, so welche hast du. Also das ist natürlich total unrealistisch. Es geht hier auch nicht um Realitätsnähe oder so. Es geht hier um ein ganzes Konzept, wie man in Zukunft mit diesem freien Netz umgehen will. Es geht um Fragen der Netzneutralität, es geht um Fragen der Haftung von Providern, es geht um die Frage, ob wir in Zukunft alle die, die Hostanbieter oder Contentanbieter sind, gleich mal zu Hilfsscherefs machen. Das ist so eine Art Denke, die aus der analogen Welt jetzt übertragen werden soll ins Netz. Also mir scheint, dass das auch ein Konzept ist.
Ich habe noch eine kleine Teilfrage. Ist dies mal geheime Verhandlungen? Wer verhandelt denn da überhaupt?
Also für Deutschland verhandelt die EU. Und ansonsten verhandeln da so Bürokraten aus den Regierungen. Also die Liste der Länder, die da an Regierungsdelegationen haben.
Also für die EU verhandelt die EU. Das heißt, wenn dieser Vertrag geschlossen wird, wäre die EU verpflichtet, dann wiederum Gesetzgebung auszumachen.
Also die würde dann daraus wahrscheinlich Richtlinien machen. Interessant ist aber auch, dass zwar keine Beteiligten aus dem Internet dabei sind, aber eine Menge große Firmen, die da mitspielen und ihre Interessen dadurch drücken.
Das heißt, wir haben hier Länder auf der einen Seite und große Unternehmen.
Die internationalen Medienkonzerne, die Hollywood Studios und die Musikindustrie, die wissen über die Inhalte dieses Abkommens besser Bescheid als die Abgeordneten im Deutschen Bundestag oder im Europäischen Parlament.
Das war eine weitere Sache, die mich verwirrt hat im Vorhinein. Die EU-Kommission verhandelt das quasi, was jetzt die Institution angeht. Und wieso darf das Parlament das nicht sehen?
Diese internationalen Verträge werden immer geheim verhandelt, weil sie sagen, wenn alle mitreden wollen, können wir gar nicht ordentlich verhandeln. Man kann jetzt halt natürlich sagen, das bedeutet, dass möglicherweise weniger von diesen internationalen Verträgen geschlossen werden. Vielleicht ist der auch ganz gut so. Gerade die Geheimhaltung dieser ACTA-Verhandlungen resultiert offensichtlich aber nicht nur daraus, dass sie versuchen, in Ruhe verhandeln zu können, was man nachvollziehen könnte, sondern eben daraus, dass sie schon wissen, dass das, was sie davor haben, entschieden, dass er verfassungsfeindlich ist und dazu zu massiven Protesten kommen wird. Und zwar gibt es jetzt in einer gewissen Konzession ans EU-Parlament, haben sie gewisse Teile der Entwürfe veröffentlicht, also Erklärungen veröffentlichten dergleichen Dinge mehr, aber die nationale Politik ist da noch ganz weit außen vor, weil bevor es die nationale Politik betrifft, ist es erst mal auf der EU-Ebene. Und dann, wenn die EU es beschlossen hat, ist halt alles viel zu spät.
Das wollte ich gerade noch fragen. Also die Verhandlungen finden im Geheimen statt. Bevor der Vertrag beschlossen wird, geht er dann noch an die Öffentlichkeit oder wird er unterzeichnet und dann veröffentlicht?
Er ist ja faktisch jetzt öffentlich geworden im Netz. Aber man muss natürlich sehen, dass die offiziellen Entscheider hier in Deutschland, die klicken sich sowas nicht im Netz, die warten, bis sie das auf ihren Schreibtisch kriegen, über die offiziellen Wege in der offiziellen Übersetzung.
Ja genau, das war erst mal die Frage, wie ist der offizielle Werdegang in so einer geheimen Verhandlung? Kommen die irgendwann zu einem Abschluss und bevor das unterschrieben wird, wird das veröffentlicht oder?
Also in der EU muss seit dem Lissabon-Vertrag auf jeden Fall das Parlament da zustimmen. Die haben da Mitspracherecht. Nur haben die halt bisher noch nicht gesagt bekommen, was da eigentlich wirklich verhandelt wird und die drucksen da unheimlich rum und sagen, ja ja, sie wollen das transparenter machen, aber de facto steht jetzt schon mehr im Internet an geleakten Dokumenten darüber, als die EU in den letzten Jahren darüber veröffentlicht hat. Aber ich wollte noch mal eben nur der Vollständigkeit halber auch kurz die Länder nennen. Also 27 Mitgliedstaaten der Europäischen Union vertreten durch die EU-Kommission, die Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika, Japan, Kanada, Südkorea, Mexiko, Neuseeland, die Schweiz, Australien, Jordanien, Marokko, Singapur und die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate, plus zwei Dutzend internationale Medienkonzerne sitzen da am Tisch und verhandeln in hinter verschlossenen Türen, wie sie die technische Entwicklung der letzten 20 Jahre zurückdrehen können. Darauf läuft es doch hinaus.
Also interessant daran sind die Argumentationslinien, mit denen sie dann halt in nationale Parlamente gehen werden. Weil alle diese Staaten sind ja Staaten, in denen geistiges Eigentum in der Wirtschaft, zumindest nach Auffassung der Regierenden, eine große Rolle spielt. Und die halt fürchten, dass sie da ins Hintertreffen geraten, wenn die Chinesen halt freudig weiter kopieren. Und das ist halt so der Antrieb, mit dem sie halt an die Regierungen rangehen. Und genauso wird es dann halt auch in den Parlamenten verkauft. Weil sie sagen, ja, da sind ja zwar so ein paar Kröten dabei, aber wenn wir jetzt irgendwie gar nichts unternehmen, dann geht es unserer Wirtschaft noch viel, viel schlechter, weil die Chinesen kommen ja. Und das ist halt so eben genau diese Verknüpfung von geistigen Eigentum bei Produkten und solchen Geschichten, wo man nachvollziehen kann, dass es da halt so etwas geben sollte, mit halt irgendwie den Interessen der Content-Mafia, die halt einfach völlig überbordend sind.
Frank meint damit, die Musik und Filmindustrie.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, Content-Mafia, also wenn es Fußnoten gäbe, müsste man das jedes Mal einfügen, aber danke.
Ja bitte, gerne.
Okay, so, also wir haben jetzt schon Netzsperren, wir haben schon ACTA. Wir brauchen noch einen Jugendmedienstaatsvertrag. Dazu kommen wir aber erst nach den Nachrichten über Dornverkehr.
Ich liebe Fußball.
Soll ich gleich noch mal sagen?
Nein, jetzt noch nicht. Das Fritz-Soccer-Team sucht wieder begeisterte Freizeitfußballer für die Saison 2010. Euch schwingt jede Menge Ruhm, Ehre und Zuschauer. Allerdings nur, wenn ihr es ins Team schafft.
Soll ich es jetzt noch mal sagen?
Nein, jetzt kommt auch das Allerwichtigste. Wenn ihr im Fritz-Team mitspielen wollt, dann kommt zum Fritz-Soccer-Team-Sichtungstag ins Berliner Olympiastadion. Am Ostersamstag im Rahmen des Nike Premier Cup.
Moment noch. Also, kommenden Samstag. Treffpunkt ist um 10 Uhr. Vorm Eingang der Geschäftsstelle von Hertha BSC in der Ansbraunstraße. Ne, jetzt ist zu spät.
Mit Mario Bartsch.
Zu den Terroranschlägen von Moskau haben sich islamistische Rebellen aus dem Nordkaukasus bekannt. Ihr Anführer erklärte in einem Internetvideo, die Anschläge seien ein Racheakt dafür, dass russische Sicherheitskräfte Zivilisten getötet hätten. Der Rebellenführer kündigte weitere Anschläge an. Zwei Selbstmordattentäterinnen hatten in der Moskauer Metro am Montag 39 Menschen mit in den Tod gerissen. Bei zwei weiteren Selbstmordanschlägen wurden heute mindestens 12 Menschen in der sudrussischen Provinz Dagestan getötet. Die internationale Staatengemeinschaft stellt Haiti für den Wiederaufbau nach dem Erdbeben vor 2, 5 Monaten mehrere Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung. Das ist das Ergebnis einer Geberkonferenz der Vereinten Nationen in New York. Das meiste Geld versprach Venezuela mit umgerechnet 1, 6 Milliarden Euro. Große Geldsummen sagten auch die EU und die USA zu. Bei dem Beben waren in Haiti rund 230.000 Menschen ums Leben gekommen und 100.000 obdachlos geworden. Zur Enttäuschung von Umweltschützern hat US-Präsident Obama Teile der US-Küste für Öl- und Gasbohrungen freigegeben. Sie seien notwendig, um den amerikanischen Energiebedarf zu decken und Arbeitsplätze zu sichern, sagte Obama. Er wolle auch alternative Energien weiter fördern. Betroffen sind die Ostküste am Atlantik und die Südküste am Golf von Mexiko. Im Basketball Eurocup hat Alba Berlin als erste deutsche Mannschaft überhaupt die Final-Vorrunde erreicht. Die Berliner besiegten im Viertelfinalrückspiel Jerusalem mit 72 zu 59 und machten damit die 61 zu 67 Niederlage aus dem Hinspiel der Wett. Heute Nacht gibt es ein paar Wolken, aber meist bleibt es trocken. Die Tiefstemperaturen liegen um ein Grad. Am Tag dann maximal zwölf Grad. Zunächst ist das längere Zeit heiter. Später gibt es häufiger Wolken und vor allem in Richtung Prignitz und Hafenland auch Regen und Krautelschauer. A9 Berlin Richtung Halle Leipzig zwischen Beelitz-Heilstetten und Beelitz gibt es nach Bergungsarbeiten Sperrungen der rechten Spur und der linken Spur. Nein, der rechten Spur benutzt bitte die linke Spur, so muss es heißen. A10 westlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Dreieck-Hafenland zwischen Potsdam Nord und Spandau. Wegen Bergungsarbeiten ist die Autobahn da gesperrt. A11 Pomellen Richtung Berlin zwischen Joachimstal und Korinne gab es einen Unfall mit mehreren Fahrzeugen. Auch da ist die Autobahn gesperrt. A13 Dresden Richtung Berlin zwischen Ortrand und Ruland. Gefahr durch ein defektes Fahrzeug auf dem Standstreifen. Außerdem befinden sich da Personen auf der Fahrbahn. Fahrt da entsprechend vorsichtig. Sonst überall gute Fahrzeuge.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 89, 85 dann Fritz im Berliner Kabel.
Und wenn du sie auch nicht kenn, dann sag ich dir, dass du sie auch nicht kennst. Und wenn du sie auch nicht kennst, dann sag ich dir, dass du sie auch nicht kennst. Und wenn du sie auch nicht kennst, dann sag ich dir, dass du sie. Und wenn du sie auch nicht kennst, dann sag ich dir, dass du sie auch nicht kennst. Und wenn du sie auch nicht kennst, dann sag ich dir, dass du sie auch nicht kennst. Und die Jugend soll auch noch geschützt werden. Wir haben jetzt schon darüber gesprochen, wie die Netzsperren funktionieren, beziehungsweise wie sie nicht funktionieren. Außerdem ging es um ACTA, ein Gesetzeswerk oder ein internationaler Vertrag, der gerade im Geheimen verhandelt wird, wo es auch darum geht, dass man das Internet zum Beispiel sperrt, wenn jemand böse war, oder dass man eure Festplatte durchsucht, wenn ihr mal am Flieger seid und eine Grenze überschreitet. Was uns jetzt in dem Bundestrauß noch fehlt, ist der sogenannte Jugend-Medien-Staatsvertrag. Da gibt es auch einen neuen Entwurf und was steht da drin?
Naja, also da geht es um den sogenannten Jugendschutz in Medien. Die Leute, die sich das ausdenken, die leben noch irgendwie so 1850 mit Röhrenradio und sowas.
Aber geile Hemden.
Jaja.
Also mehr so 1950.
Ja, 1950 mit Röhrenradio oder so. Aber auf jeden Fall schon.
Aber geile Tapete.
Für...
Jaja, Markus.
Für Internetverhältnisse irgendwie letztes Jahr 1000 oder vorletztes.
Na Männer, könnt ihr euch mal ein bisschen konzentrieren.
Meine Lederjacke, die kommt...
Und um was es da geht, ist, dass sie versuchen, fürs Internet ähnliche Regelungen festzuschreiben, wie man das von früher vom Fernsehen kennt. So Sendezeiten, Sendezeitbegrenzung. So der Tatort mit den Gewaltszenen darf erst nach 22 Uhr gezeigt werden. Das soll jetzt auch im Internet gelten. Ich frage da immer gerne zurück, könnt ihr überhaupt die Frage beantworten, wann es im Internet 22 Uhr ist? Also wenn mir das jemand beantworten kann, bitte ruft an. Ihr wisst 0331...
Wie spät ist es eigentlich gerade im Internet? Eine Frage, die wir heute gerne klären würden, bitte anrufen, wenn ihr es wisst.
Ich glaube, es ist 13 Uhr im Netz, oder?
13.37 Ja genau.
Also die Bündel an Maßnahmen, was in diesem Staatsvertrag festgeschrieben wird und was jetzt gerade sozusagen noch dann von den einzelnen Landesparlamenten noch zustimmungsfähig ist. Das ist alles irgendwie optional. Das heißt, derjenige, der etwa eine Webseite betreibt, kann sich aussuchen, ob er eine Altersverifikation einfügt oder eben nicht. Oder Sendezeiten sich diesem fügt. Auf jeden Fall ist es aber eine Struktur, die nachher als Ergebnis haben soll, dass sich etwa Eltern kleine Programme auf den Rechner spielen können und damit fertige Software haben, die helfen soll, den Sprösslingen bestimmte Teile des Netzes vorzuteilen.
Und lass mich raten, wenn ich mich als Webseitenbetreiber zu entschließe, meine Seite nicht zu labeln, ist sie automatisch ab 18?
So werden diese Programme vermutlich daherkommen.
Nee, wenn sie nicht gelabelt ist, wird sie sowieso gesperrt.
Also vollständig oder was?
Genau, dann können die Kinder nicht sehen.
Es ist halt so, dass diese komischen Jugendschutzprogramme, die soll natürlich entsprechend zertifiziert werden. Das stand doch schon im vorigen Jugendmehlenstaatsvertrag drin. Es gibt bis heute keins, was irgendwie richtig zertifiziert ist.
Also der letzte ist aus dem Jahr 2004. Also es gibt überhaupt noch kein System. Das haben die da auch schon beschlossen. Das ist ja dieselbe Sicht.
Wer soll das zertifizieren? TÜV, Stiftung Warentest?
Was war das, die KJM oder was?
Genau, die KJM ist so eine Kommission, die sich um sowas kümmert. Und zwar, was ist denn das ausgesprochen KJM? Ich weiß es jetzt gar nicht. Kultur- und Kulturjugendmedien.
Das sind doch die selben, die auch Computerspiele zensieren.
Genau. Und da hängt auch noch die freiwillige Selbstkontrolle drin.
Die haben ja schon immer ihre Kompetenz bewiesen. Das sind also erfahrene Experten.
Das ist die Kommission für den Jugendmedienschutz, so heißt es KJM.
Genau. Eine der Gefahren, die wir halt sehen, ist, dass wenn so ein Labeling flächendeckend durchgedrückt wird, dann kann es halt sehr einfach dazu kommen, dass Internetanbieter, also Disney Internet anbieten, also dass sie sagen, hier gibt es halt irgendwie Kinderinternet für ein Film mal extra.
Das ist auch so eine komische Übertragung, als würde man den Staat plötzlich in der Rolle sehen, den Jugendschutz vor den heimischen Rechnern auszuüben. Das ist so ein merkwürdiges Gesicht, dass man stellt so eine Software hin, und dann können die Eltern noch klicken und schon sind die dunklen Ecken aus dem Netz weg. Und dann kann man, wie früher, wo man die Kinder vom Fernseher geparkt hat, sie jetzt von dem Rechner parken, ohne dass man sich noch kümmern braucht, weil der Staat hat ja quasi schon alles reguliert. Das ist quasi die Sicht, und das ist natürlich ein bisschen bedenklich, weil man natürlich sehen muss, dass hier auch über ältere Kinder gesprochen wird, denen man eigentlich ab 14 oder 16 schon Medienkompetenzen hat beibringen müssen, wenn sie natürlich auch in der Schule, in der Freizeit und auf ihrem Mobiltelefon mit dem Netz umgehen. Also da ist so eine seltsame, auch sehr kontrollwütige Sicht. Natürlich haben sich insbesondere die Staatskanzlei Rheinland-Pfalz, die jetzt da betroffen war, die haben sich über die Medienaufmerksamkeit sehr gewundert, weil normalerweise diese Staatsverträge nicht eben von sehr viel Öffentlichkeit umgeben sind. Also dass sie sich jetzt da rechtfertigen mussten, teilweise für Sachen, die schon im 2004er-Vertrag enthalten haben, hat die doch ziemlich überrascht. Und sie betonen jetzt natürlich immer, dass Sperren das letzte Mittel sei. Nur wenn gar nichts anderes mehr greift, müsste man halt zu Sperren greifen. Da steckt natürlich dieselbe Sicht dahinter, die wir bei Zensursula gesehen haben, oder die wir jetzt aus Europa sehen.
Was die ja noch nicht begriffen haben, genauso wie das im Zusammenhang mit den Netzsperren im Bezug auf Kinderpornografie, sogenannte Kinderpornografie, noch nicht gemerkt haben, ist ja, dass jeder Filter ist detektierbar. Das ist einfach technisch so. Alles, wo du einen Filter reinhängst, da kannst du den Filter detektieren. Du kannst feststellen, dass der Filter da ist. Und du kannst feststellen, was er filtert. Und genau aus diesem Grunde führen sämtliche Sperrlisten, egal wie geheim man versucht sie zu halten, dazu, dass man im Endeffekt eine Liste aller interessanten Domains für die jeweilig angesprochene Zielgruppe bereitstellt und öffentlich verbreitet. Und das soll jetzt gesetzlich geregelt und mit Steuergeldern finanziert werden. Der Staat erstellt die gelben Seiten der Kinderpornosszene und die ganzen interessanten Seiten, wo Kinder nicht drauf kommen sollen. Aber wir wissen alle, wie das ist mit Verboten und so.
Wir haben Janik vorhin gehört. Janik fällt natürlich aus dieser Definition sehr klar darunter.
Ich möchte dazu mal ein Zitat von Erich Kessner bringen. Wenn ein Kind auf der Straße spielt, ist es in Gefahr. Ziel der Erziehung und Entwicklung muss ein Leben mit den Gefahren sein. Wenn Jugendliche laut Gesetz erwachsen sind, also 18 werden, geht kein geheimnisvoller Vorhang auf und erleuchtet den Jugendlichen, um plötzlich selbstverantwortlich handeln zu können. Entweder wir schaffen es, unseren Kindern auf diesen Gefahren schon in ihrer Entwicklung vorzubereiten. Oder es kommt zum kleinen Schock, wenn plötzlich der Erwachsenenvorhang fällt. Glücklicherweise wussten es schon viele Jugendlichen, wie wir auch, diese Verbote zu umgehen. Und um uns vorher schlau zu machen, könnten wir dieses Versteckspiel nun endlich mal sein lassen. Ja, Erich Kessner hat es gerafft, unsere Politiker haben es noch nicht gerafft.
Von wann ist es?
Weiß ich nicht, genau. Der steht hier nicht dabei bei einem Zitat.
Aber ist das der Gegenvorschlag? Wir machen gar nichts?
Also ich meine, Medienkompetenz ist der Gegenvorschlag und das ist der einzigste Gegenvorschlag, der funktioniert. Ich habe heute mit einer Zwölfjährigen gesprochen. Und hallo Raya, wenn du uns zuhörst übrigens. Und die hat mich gefragt, was denn dieses Jugendmedienschutz-Dings da ist. Die hat irgendwie davon gehört. Und dann habe ich versucht ihr das zu erklären. Ist nicht ganz so einfach, so was mit einer Zwölfjährigen zu erklären. Aber die meinte dann, wie? Die wollen, dass ich nur noch mit diesem doofen Fragfinn suchen kann und mich von Google aussperren? Die haben sie wohl nicht mehr alle.
Also wenn es verpflichten wird, ist natürlich auch klar, dass jeder, der bei Verstand ist, seine Webseite ab 18 raten wird. Schon für die Altersverifikation. Schon damit er keinen Ärger kriegt und dass er nicht alle Kommentare rausfischen muss, die eventuell jugendgefährdende Inhalte haben. Das heißt, das wird auch dazu führen, dass es einfach schon aus der Bequemlichkeit halber die Leute ab 18 raten, weil sie keinen Ärger wollen.
Die bequeme Variante ist, deinen Blog nach sonst wohin zu verschiffen.
Ja, das stimmt natürlich.
Aber noch mal detailliert, wenn ich eine Webseite betreibe, wo möglicherweise fremde Leute Kommentare einstellen können oder irgend so etwas in der Preislage, also quasi wenn ich einen Blog habe, dann kann ich ja vorher nicht garantieren, was für Inhalte da reinkommen. Das heißt, ich müsste sie entweder ständig kontrollieren oder gleich sagen ab 18.
Genau. Aber ich meine, du hast jetzt auch gewisse Pflichten, die sind unabhängig vom Jugendschutz, hast du gewisse Pflichten, dich um Strafbarinhalte in deinen Foren oder in deinem Comments und Blog zu kümmern. Aber das würde dich natürlich auf eine andere Ebene gehoben. Denn jung gefährdend oder gewaltverherrlichend oder dergleichen fängt relativ früh an. Das heißt, du müsstest deine Kommentare schon zeitnah durchsehen. Also wirst du wahrscheinlich den Weg gehen, wenn du ohnehin eigentlich nicht Kinder besonders ansprichst, sondern eben ein normaler Blog hast, ja, für Erwachsene im Wesentlichen. Dann wirst du sie auf 18 raten, schon um den Ärger nicht zu haben. Also das ist ja auch eine Zeitfrage, ja. Man muss auch mal überlegen. Also Kommentare zeitnah durchzugehen ist einfach ein ziemlicher Nerv für einen gut funktionierenden Blog.
Okay, jetzt haben wir bei den Netzsperren ist irgendwie die Hoffnung gesetzt, auf die Aktivisten, die denselben Aufschlag machen wie hier in Deutschland. Bei ACTA müssen wir gucken, dass die europäischen Parlamentarier vielleicht dann irgendwie abstimmen. Was geht beim Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrag?
Na, da wird natürlich jetzt erstmal versucht über die Landesparlamenten, die Parlamente, die ja sehr unterschiedlich besetzt sind mit den Parteien, dann nochmal Druck zu machen. Also das wird quasi nochmal, eigentlich nochmal inhaltlich auch überarbeitet werden muss. Also das ist natürlich sehr schwierig, weil ja bei den 16 Bundesländern eine ziemlich schwierige Gemengenlage ist, aber wir hoffen doch, dass einige Parteien das jetzt verstanden haben und über die Landesparlamente doch nochmal neu verhandelt werden muss.
Also ich wollte mal kurz erklären, wie dieser Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrag tatsächlich zustande kommt. Das ist ja ganz interessant, gerade für den Ansatz, wo man protestieren kann. Verhandelt wird dieser Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrag von den Rundfunkreferenten der Länder. Das heißt, es sind nicht mal irgendwelche gewählten Leute, sondern die sind halt von den jeweiligen Landesregierungen eingesetzt.
Also Rundfunk, nur noch mal zur Betonung.
Also Rundfunk. Also sind halt die, die sich normalerweise mit diesen Rundfunkräten da, wo die Pfaffen sitzen und so. Und dieses Grimen, was halt keinerlei Kompetenz fürs Internet bisher bewiesen hat, verhandelt hat untereinander diesen Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrag. Der wird dann von den Ministerpräsidenten unterschrieben. Also bei uns wird der Herr Wove reit. Und wenn die es unterschrieben haben, also der Vertrag sozusagen schon unterzeichnend ist, geht er nochmal in die Landesparlamente zum Abwägen.
Also es gibt vorher einen kleinen Schritt noch. Die Referenten informieren über ihre Ausschüsse schon, was da passiert. Aber das ist keine Abstimmung mit den Landesparlamenten, sondern nur, sie sagen ihnen nur in den Ausschüssen, was sie da gerade verhandelt haben. Also das ist eine reine Information. Das heißt, die Parlamentarierinnen und Parlamentarier haben überhaupt da gar keine Stimme zu.
Das heißt, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, gibt es das nur einmal diesen Schritt, nämlich bei der Unterschrift durch den Ministerpräsidenten des Landes.
Na ja, theoretisch könnten jetzt, nachdem die Ministerpräsidenten ja gesagt haben, ja, wir stimmen dem zu, die Landesparlamente meuten. Das könnte schon passieren.
Das ist wie wahrscheinlich?
Also das letzte Mal, als es passiert ist, war in Sachsen bei, was war es für ein Staatsvertrag?
Nee, war das nicht irgendwas mit der, mit Föderalismus?
Das reicht aber, wenn ein Bundesland meutert.
Genau, aber die haben dann halt so richtig auf die Mütze bekommen von allen, weil nach dem Motto, aber ihr hättet doch vorher schon mal was sagen können.
Ich denke, man kann vorher nichts sagen.
Na, sie können halt schon, also sie bekommen es ja nicht mit. Wir haben halt hier mit Berliner Politikern geredet, die wussten davon einfach nichts.
Hey, sprecht doch den Abgeordneten an.
Diese Staatsverträge sind tatsächlich oft unter dem Radar. Das läuft dann ein bisschen an den Parlamenten vorbei. Da einigen sich ja diese Rundfunkreferenten. Hier in diesem Fall ist natürlich auch die KJM da noch federführend dabei. Also die wir schon genannt haben, die Kommission für Jugend und Medien. Da haben einfach die Parlamentarier ja auch überhaupt keine Informationen auf dem Schreibtisch.
Was ist denn so ein Staatsvertrag, wenn er dann gilt? Also ist es dann ein Gesetz oder ist es dann sozusagen ein Hinweis für die Politiker, kümmert euch doch mal drum? Oder ist es so eine Art schickes Schreiben?
Das ist eine total gute Frage und das ist mir zum Beispiel auch nicht so ganz klar. Also es ist schon sowas Gesetzesmäßiges, aber auf Landesebene. Allerdings, es heißt ja auch nicht Gesetz, es heißt ja Staatsvertrag.
So liebe Politikwissenschafts-Studenten, die ihr da draußen sitzt, jetzt gilt für euch Folgendes. 0331 70 97 110 Weil vielleicht ist ja die ganze Aufregung total umsonst, weil so ein Staatsvertrag so eine Art Klopapier ist.
Also wir brauchen glaube ich keine große juristische Expertise. Der Punkt ist, dass Sachen, die die Länder in Deutschland zu regeln haben, die also nicht der Bund regelt über diese Staatsverträge, wie etwa auch der Rundfunkstaatsvertrag. Insofern, die gelten schon unmittelbar. Wir haben halt nur beim letzten Staatsvertrag 2004 zum Jugendmedienschutz gesehen, dass nicht unbedingt sofort eine direkte Folge kommt. Nämlich etwa, dass eben die Software für solche Sperren gar nicht zur Verfügung gestellt wird. Das zieht Sicherheit. Aber es tritt schon unmittelbar an Kraft. Also teils die Länder sind da oft dran gebunden. Das ist ja nicht so eine Möchte-Regelung.
Also der Staatsvertrag regelt. Also es ist eigentlich ein Übereinkommen zwischen den Ländern, entsprechende Regelungen zu schaffen.
Also ein Vertrag zwischen den Ländern, ein Vertrag zwischen den Bundesländern sozusagen.
Genau, also die Bundesländer kommen überein, weil ja Kultur ist ja eine Ländersache, kommen überein, einheitliche Regelungen in ihren Ländern jeweils zu schaffen.
Ok, also es wird kein Gesetz der Bundesregierung entlassen, aber im Prinzip ist es sowas ähnliches. Wir haben ein deutschlandweites geltendes Geldlehrsabkommen. Ok, jetzt haben wir also den bunten Strauß. ACTA, Jugendmedienschutz, Staatsvertrag und Netzsperren. Fehlt noch was?
Na ja, wir haben jetzt natürlich noch die Initiative von unserer schönen Censilia Malmström, die ja auf dasselbe hinausläuft wie die deutsche Zensur, ein Zugangserschwerungsgesetz.
Achso, das hätte ich jetzt sozusagen unter Netzsperren mit abgehakt. Aber bei den drei Sachen bleiben wir jetzt erstmal.
Oder gibt es die? Im Wesentlichen sind das die drei Sachen.
Ok, gut, dann können wir jetzt nämlich mit Chris reden. Der wollte nämlich was zu einer bunten Blume aus diesem Strauß sagen, zu den Netzsperren.
Hallo Chris.
Ihr seid jetzt thematisch ja schon ein bisschen weiter nach vorne gekommen.
Das war quasi die Einführung. Jetzt geht's los.
Also wir meandern heute eigentlich die ganze Zeit. Stell einfach deine Frage.
Ne, eigentlich habe ich nicht unbedingt eine Frage, sondern es geht mir so ein bisschen darum, sozusagen meine Sicht, warum überhaupt dieser ganze Aufwand gemacht wird mit den Internetsperren, weil ich glaube, die Motive dafür sind ganz unterschiedlich.
Da sind wir aber gespannt. Dann mal raus damit.
Ich glaube, die Motive sind eigentlich nicht wirklich so was wie Kinderpornos aus dem Internet verbannt oder Raubkopiere aus dem Internet verbannt. Das ist einfach immer nur ein angenehmer Nebeneffekt. Aber ich denke, es geht vor allem einfach darum, dieses Gefühl von Sicherheit zu schaffen. Also einfach nur dieses, den Leuten zeigen zu können, seht her, diese Umgebung ist für euch total sicher. Und vor allem für die Leute, die wirtschaftliche Interessen haben, ist das ja super. Weil wenn wir zum Beispiel irgendwo einen Laden aufmachen möchten in einem Gebiet, wo klar ist, dass die Kriminalitätsrate hoch ist, dann will ich da nicht hin. Deswegen, wenn mir jemand sagt, das ist alles total super hier und das ist total friedlicher, dann gehe ich da hin und stelle da meinen Laden hin. Ich glaube, dieses gefühlte Sichersein, das ist viel wichtiger. Da fällt mir ein banales Beispiel ein. Ich wohne in Hamburg und ich weiß jetzt, dass jemand von euch vielleicht kennt. Bei der Reeperbahn haben sie jetzt schon seit einigen Jahren ein Schild mit so stilisierten Waffen.
Keine Messer, keine CS-Gas, keine Schlagstöcke habe ich gesehen.
Ich bin ja schon mein Leben lang hier und deswegen kannte ich ja auch die ganze Umgebung da sowieso schon, wie sie halt einfach immer war. Und jetzt sind halt diese Schilder da und habe ich mir auch gedacht, okay, welcher Verbrecher denkt sich jetzt, oh Mist, jetzt habe ich meine Handgranaten gerade dabei, die darf ich jetzt ja hier gar nicht unterwegs dabei haben. Was ist das für eine Idee?
Na ja, aber die haben doch einen Wattelmann, haben die nicht in der Reeperbahn ohne Handy Videoüberwachung? Da müssten die doch eigentlich schon abgeschreckt sein, wie Sau.
Das kommt noch hinzu, wir haben jetzt diese Kameras da und dann denke ich mir halt auch, okay, ihr könnt jetzt irgendwie den ganzen Leuten hier auf die Gesichter gucken, aber dass zum Beispiel solche Dinge passieren, wie, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitbekommen habt, da hat mal irgendein Irrer, glaube ich, eine Frau vor die Bahn geschmissen und dann stand da halt eben überall ganz groß, ja, aber wir haben ja die Kameraaufnahmen und so, aber keiner verhindert, dass er diese Frau davor schmeißt.
Na ja klar, also eine Videokamera hat sich noch nie. Aber der Punkt ist ja, du argumentierst jetzt so ein bisschen über diese Sicherheit und so ein bisschen so ein Wohlfühlinternetz oder meinst du, also schon durchaus einen positiven Grund für diese Netzsperren?
Ob das jetzt für mich persönlich positiv ist.
Na ja, ich meine, das ist ja eine positive Motivation, die du jetzt beschreibst, oder? Was sicher machen, zumindest subjektiv sicher und angenehm.
Das ist das, was ich glaube, was die eigentliche Idee davon ist, das so zu machen, dass ich das für richtig halte, das ist eine ganz andere Frage. Ich halte das für grundsätzlich vollständig schwachsinnig. Also ich bin selber auch Entwickler und habe selber viel mit Technik zu tun, gerade natürlich auch viel mit Internet und so weiter. Ich habe sogar noch, als die Sendung gerade angefangen hat, weil ich kenne ja noch die vorherigen Sendungen, und dann hat ja vorhin der, ich habe schon wieder seinen Namen vergessen, aber der war ja auf jeden Fall 14. Yannick, genau. Und ich habe mir vorher noch gedacht, ich kenne 14-
15-
16-Jährige, die sind so pleatsch schon, die können mit N-Map umgehen, die sind teilweise auf der Shell schneller als ich.
Okay, du kennst die alte Chaosradio-Regel, die ich gerade nur eingeführt habe.
Oh, wie ist die denn?
Die ist, wenn du einen Begriff verwenden willst, den möglicherweise, wo der vergründete Verdacht besteht, wenn es nicht verstanden wird, dann musst du ihn erklären. Was ist N-Map?
Okay, N-Map ist ein Programm, um festzustellen, ja ich sag jetzt mal, um das für die Allgemeinheit zu machen. Portscanner. Genau, es ist ein Portscanner. Ja, bedeutet so viel wie, dass ich praktisch jede mögliche offene Leitung an einem Computer einmal abklopfe, um zu gucken, ob sie gerade offen ist, ob ich vielleicht irgendwie Schindluder damit heilen kann.
Also man kann das auch zu positiven Zwecken benutzen, zum Beispiel mit eigenem Netz zu checken.
Das ist richtig, ich erinnere mich nur an so Diskussionen mit Felix und auch über die Hacker-Tools.
Oh ja, das war eine denkwürdige Sendung, du hast natürlich recht.
Nochmal wieder ein ganz anderes Thema. Aber was ich auf jeden Fall meine, ist, dass die Kids heute mit Sachen umgehen können, die ich in dem Alter auf jeden Fall noch nicht kannte. Und wenn ich mich an sowas erinnere, was die Frau von der Leyen von sich gegeben hat, wo sie dann irgendwie meint, ja, das sind ja nur ganz versierte Benutzer, die damit umgehen können, es ist wirklich Quatsch, es ist völliger Unsinn. Ich bin zwar selber, würde ich zwar sagen, okay, ich bin technikaffin, ja, aber wenn ich Leute angucke, die ein bestimmtes Interesse haben, also wirklich Leute, wo ich sagen würde, okay, die sind etwas einfacher gestrickt, ja, also, wie sagt man, sind wir uns wundervoll.
Schaffen die das auch, ist schon klar, oder?
Ja, die schaffen es trotzdem. Wenn einige Counter-Strike spielen möchten oder was auch immer, was er machen möchte, erreicht dieses Ziel ja trotzdem irgendwann.
Meine Vermutung war ja auch, als ich gehört habe, dass bei diesem Jugendmedienschutz-Staatsvertrag irgendwie, dass sie darüber reden, da Filterprogramme, und die Eltern sollen dann irgendwie den Internetzugang ihrer Kinder filtern. Meine erste Idee war ja, dass die Kids bestimmt da hergehen und dieses Programm irgendwie so umkonfigurieren, dass Papa irgendwie keine Recherchen mehr in Holland machen kann, und Mama ihr Blog nicht mehr klicken kann, bis es eine saftige Taschengelderhöhung gibt. Wer konfiguriert denn die Videorekorder zu Hause und alles? Das machen irgendwie die Kids, nicht die Eltern, weil Mama weiß gar nicht, wie das geht. Und ich meine, wenn ich mir das angucke und dann Politiker höre, die sagen, ja wir können den Tatort erst um 22 Uhr bringen, weil da ist eine Gewaltszene drin. Ich meine, der Kleene, der schläft um 22 Uhr, aber der hat den Videorekorder programmiert. Das ist doch alles total ballerballer, was die da machen. Und im Internet wird das halt genauso laufen. Da werden die Kids die Filter für die Eltern konfigurieren, bis es eine saftige Taschengelderhöhung gibt. Und das mit dem Labeling funktioniert ja sowieso nicht, weil wisst ihr, was da draußen im Internet heutzutage vor allem gelabelt ist? Irgendwelche Wortmeldungen hier im Studio oder am Telefon?
Ich weiß gar nicht, worauf du hinaus willst.
Na, die einzigsten Seiten, die heutzutage im Internet gelabelt sind, sind Porno-Seiten. Und wisst ihr, warum die gelabelt sind? Damit man sie besser findet. Und wisst ihr, warum die freiwillig ihre Seiten labeln? Weil sie gemerkt haben, dass ihnen das Traffic bringt. Und wisst ihr, was passiert, wenn sie jetzt staatlich verordnet alles labeln lassen? Das führt dazu, dass die Kids die wirklich interessanten Seiten, die sie nicht sehen sollen, viel schneller finden als bisher.
Ja, das muss man ein bisschen korrigieren. Es gibt natürlich auch ein Jugendlabeling in vielen Ländern der Welt. Das gibt es schon. Und es gibt auch einige Projekte, wo man sagen kann, gerade für kleine Kinder mag das auch noch sinnvoll sein. Also sagen wir mal bis 6 oder 8. Aber er hat natürlich recht, wenn er sagt, dass im Wesentlichen das Labeling über Pornseiten läuft.
Positiv labeling, dass Webseiten, die halt zertifiziert kindgerechten Content haben.
Also nur weil sich das Guzi jetzt hier in der Ratsche redet.
Also das hat die Seite von der Sendung mit der Maus halten, dann entsprechend, dass irgendwie es gut ab Null Jahren Label oder solche Dinge hat. Das macht natürlich schon einen gewissen Sinn, dass man da halt einfach nen...
Ich finde, man muss auch stärker unterscheiden zwischen sehr kleinen Kindern, die man aber ohnehin auf keinen Fall alleine am Rechner lassen soll. Man muss sich einfach überlegen, wie man nicht wollte, dass das kleine Kind den Fernseher bedient. Also will man natürlich den auch nicht alleine am Rechner lassen.
Du meinst, Eltern sollen sich um ihre Kinder kümmern?
Zumindest bis vor einiger Zeit war das mal ein akzeptiertes Konzept.
Naja, also wer sein Kind, gerade ein kleines Kind vom Fernseher parkt, ist für mich kein Stück besser. Vielleicht, Frank, du hast ja ein ganz gutes Konzept. Vielleicht willst du mal erzählen, was du selbst für sinnvoll hältst.
Also bei uns ist es halt so, dass die... Da gibt es halt einen öffentlichen Familiencomputer, der halt nicht irgendwie so steht, dass man da unbeobachtet drauf surfen kann. Das heißt also, die... Also es ist halt immer sozusagen mehr oder minder wie gemeinsames Fernsehen gucken, wenn man da klickt. Was halt dazu fehlt.
Wie alt sind deine Kinder?
Die sind jetzt 6, 13, 15. Und jetzt fängt natürlich langsam der Punkt an, wo sie dann halt auch einen eigenen Computer brauchen, klar. So, also gerade die älteren, aber...
Aber da sind sie schon medienkompetent, wenn sie 15 sind.
Das heißt also, da ist halt der... genau diese Hinführung zur Medienkompetenz bedeutet eben auch, dass man sich darum kümmert. Also, dass halt zumindest nicht vollständig ignoriert wird, was da passiert.
Das nervt halt, diese ganze protektionistische Kontrollwütige, dass sich der Staat diesen Dingen annimmt. Wenn man an unsere eigenen Kindheit und Jugendliche in diese Zeit denkt, dann wird man schnell feststellen, naja, gut, wir haben auch eine Menge Regen übertreten.
Ich hab da mal Sachen gespielt wie Doom und Quake.
Ich auch.
Und die erste Platte, die ich hatte, war Die Ärzte aber 18.
Grundsätzlich sowieso keiner spielen eigentlich. Lassen wir das jetzt mal außen vor. Aber ich hab so bestimmte Dinge auf jeden Fall, oder jeder kennt das ja eigentlich, man hat ja doch immer wieder mal mit Dingen Kontakt, die erstmal noch nicht wirklich seinem Alter entsprechen. Und meiner Meinung nach ist es eigentlich immer nur eine Frage, wie man von vornherein an das Ganze herangeführt wird. Weil, wenn ich mir jetzt halt so Dinge angucke, wie so bestimmte Leute, die ich damals gesehen hab, gegen die ich unter anderem dann auch solche Spiele gespielt hab, da hat man dann auch gesehen, welche jetzt diejenigen sind, die super in diese Kategorie Killerspielspieler passen. Oder halt jemand, der einfach nur mal...
Du meinst Tötungs-Simulationssoftware?
Jetzt komm ich nicht umhin, auch mal ein bisschen zu mehr anderen. Das muss ich kurz einfügen, wo ihr gerade Killerspiele sagt. Es gab auf Golem nämlich einen schönen Artikel, dass die US-Armee jetzt gerade anfängt, das Ausbildungsprogramm für ihre Rekruten umzubauen, weil die hätten zu viel Computer gespielt, also insbesondere zu viele Killerspiele, was so die Oberen der US-Armee dazu führt, dass die Jungs ganz verweichlicht sind und keine Ahnung mehr davon haben, wie man kämpft. Fand ich beachtlich.
Das interessante dazu ist sogar noch, ich bin jetzt gerade in der Online-Spiele-Entwicklung. Ich habe nicht direkt als Entwickler, aber trotzdem habe ich immer ein bisschen Einblick darin, wie das ein bisschen aussieht mit dieser Debatte, Killerspiele und so weiter. Ich kenne die nicht wirklich, aber wir haben auf jeden Fall auch ein paar Leute in ein paar Lobbys unterwegs, wo wir ein paar Dinge dann auch herausfinden können, wie das Ganze sich gerade so entwickelt. Wir entwickeln jetzt auch bestimmte Sachen absichtlich so, dass wir das Ganze dann auch ausführen können, dass da keine Diskussion entstehen kann. Das heißt, wir beschneiden eigentlich von vornherein Konzepte, weil wir gleich wissen, dass es denen nur Ärger gibt.
Also ihr sorgt dafür, dass sie einen irgendwie ohne...
Ja, die Sache ist ja, wenn ich sage, dieses Spiel ist ab 18 freigegeben, dann habe ich automatisch meine Zielgruppe um eine Menge beschnitten, die maximal 2 Jahre jünger ist als diese 18-Jährigen. Also versuche ich das Spiel auch für 16-Jährige zu machen. Das ist genauso wie heutzutage Filme so zusammengeschnitten werden, dass sie die 16er-Fassung so zusammenschneiden, dass sie für 12-Jährige um 20.15 Uhr gezeigt werden kann. Und so funktioniert das auch.
Na ja, klar, wir sehen auch die Entwicklung, dass für den deutschen Markt teilweise anders produziert wird von den internationalen Spielefirmen. Das ist ja schon länger der Fall.
Ja, also für mich ist das Ganze einfach nur so ein gesamtes Gefüge. Also ich glaube, das ist alles letztendlich immer nur so ein Teil von diesem ganzen Puzzle, weil ich habe eben angefangen mit den Schildern auf der Rehverbahn, aber letztendlich, glaube ich, geht das auch wirklich hoch bis auf EU-Ebene, wo man dann eben sagen kann, unser Ländeszusammenschluss ist safe und wir haben hier keine Kinderpornos mehr im Internet und wir haben hier das nicht. Und dann wird wahrscheinlich dann diese gefühlte Sicherheit für wirtschaftliche Interessen zwar nutzbar sein, aber ich glaube alle anderen werden drunter leiden. Also, beziehungsweise die Menschen gewöhnen sich über kurz oder lang dann wahrscheinlich da einfach dran.
Du sagst also Netzsperren vor allem wirtschaftlich begründet und ziehen vor allen Dingen auch wirtschaftliche Effekte dann später mal nach sich. Wenn ihr auch was dazu breitragen wollt zum Bundestrauß von Netzsperren, ACTA und Jugendbienische Staatsvertrag, das war's. Dann könnt ihr gerne anrufen.
Eure Meinung? Jetzt anrufen!
0331 70 97 110.
Chaosradio im letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Heute geht es um die Dinge, mit denen die Politik versucht, das Netz so zu machen, dass es schön sauber und geradeaus ist. So eine Art Einfamilienhaussiedlung. Wie das passieren soll, das sprechen wir heute zu Gastin Frank Rieger, Konstanze Kurz und Skusi. Guten Abend nochmal. Und ihr seid natürlich nach wie vor aufgerufen, hier anzurufen, wenn ihr mit diskutieren wollt, wenn ihr eine Meinung zum Thema habt oder wenn ihr Fragen habt, weil euch was nicht klar geworden ist. Und es geht ja letztendlich, das große Thema heute, Umgang der Politik mit Netzthemen oder mit dem bösen Internet, was ganz frei und wild ist. Und dazu will uns auch der Thomas was sagen. Hallo Thomas.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend wünsche ich euch. Ja, ich würde ganz gerne mal einsteigen in der Diskussion nochmal zum Jugendwiener Staatsvertrag zu bekommen. Ich habe ja immer noch so ein bisschen die Hoffnung, dass vielleicht eines der Länder den entsprechenden Ministerpräsidenten zu einem Nein bewegen kann. Ich muss gestehen, ich bin, sollte vielleicht meine politische Herkunft dazu sagen, ich bin Liberaler. Ich bin bei den Newies ziemlich aktiv. Ich habe da bei der CDU ziemliche Bedenken, dass es da einen Ministerpräsidenten geben wird, der da einen Nein kriegt. Aber wenn die SPD sowieso gerade mal dabei ist, sich mal ernsthaft zu überlegen, ob das mit ihrer Netzpolitikverhaltensweise in den letzten Jahren das Richtige war, dann wäre vielleicht ein Schritt in der Richtung, zu sagen, wir stimmen diesem jungen Medienstaatsvertrag nicht zu. Vielleicht schon mal der erste Schritt. Ich weiß nicht, ob es eines der SPD-Länder geben wird, die in der Lage sind, das Ding aufzuhalten. Aber ich überlege, das Abstimmungsverhalten bei diesem Staatsvertrag dürfte wahrscheinlich ähnlich sein wie im Rat.
Glaubst du, dass die Liberalen eventuell in den Ländern, wo sie an der Regierung beteiligt sind, nicht vielleicht auch noch? Sie haben sich ja sehr klar geäußert.
Ja, also ich meine, ich habe in Niedersachsen dafür Lobbying gemacht. Ich habe als erst rausgekommen und habe schon mit den entsprechenden Leuten direkt hier in Niedersachsen telefoniert, die dafür zuständig sind und die sagten mir dann, das war, wie ihr vorhin gesagt habt, das ist erstmal irgendwie völlig unterm Radar. Da kann man denen teilweise echt nicht mal einen Vorwurf machen, weil das eben ein Geheimklümmel da ist. Und ja, mein Gott, dann habe ich mit denen telefoniert und die so, was ist denn das für ein Blödsinn so? Und dann ruft man an als Bürger und sagt denen irgendwie, wie die Welt funktioniert und die sagen so, hä, das kann doch wohl nicht wahr sein.
Und haben die Julis sich da, also auch offiziell, also eure Jugendorganisation sich positioniert?
Wir haben Presse, also unser Bundesvorstand hat sich positioniert und hat gesagt, wir sind dagegen, wir haben noch keinen Antrag dagegen. Wir haben jetzt irgendwie den nächsten Bundeskongress, ich habe ehrlich gesagt, das haben wir uns geschafft, zeitlich, wegen zu vielen Themen, da auch noch einen Antrag zuzuschreiben, weil immerhin unser Bundesvorstand sich da schon positioniert hat, nämlich klar dagegen. Für mich waren jetzt irgendwie die Netzsperren und jetzt auch die EU-Netzsperren, da haben wir einen Dringlichkeitsantrag zu und den werden wir auch auf den Bundesparteitag einbringen und so. Also da sind wir dabei, da sind wir am Ball. Aber das Problem ist natürlich, dieses Ding irgendwie zu kippen erstmal, also denjenigen, die den Stabverteidigung fahren, vor allem. Das ist ein Land, was ein klares Nein ist und das Problem, das ist für manchen vielleicht auch nicht so ganz klar, wo ich nochmal drauf ausfülle, das Problem ist, wenn man eine Koalition in einem Land hat. Das ist zumindest der Ursus im Bundesrat so, wenn sich in der Koalition die beiden Partner uneinigt sind und auch nicht einigen wollen sozusagen, der eine sagt ja, der andere nein, dann ist es Ursus sich zu enthalten. Eine Enthaltung allerdings ist kein Nein. So und in dem Moment rutscht das durch, auch wenn sozusagen angenommen wir haben einen Teil der Koalition der kompletten Nein sagt und der da auch wirklich drauf beharrt und anderen der sagt ja, dann kommt es am Ende trotzdem durch, weil es kein ganzes Nein ist, sondern nur so ein Hals ist sozusagen.
Wir kennen das ja aus dem Bundesrat im Prinzip, da ist es ja so ähnlich, wenn die Gesetze zustimmungsfähig sind. Naja gut, also wir haben natürlich auch mitbekommen, dass die Julis sich gegen die Initiative der Malström-Kommissarin gewendet haben. Also das heißt, ihr Vater ja eigentlich offenbar dieselbe Linie wie die meisten Jugendorganisationen der Parteien. Also das ihr sagt, Netzperren wollen wir nicht. Ich glaube auch, dass da die Problematik ganz gut angekommen ist. Aber beim Jugendmedienstaatsvertrag scheint es ein bisschen, das scheint mir jetzt auch von dem, was du sagst, so ein bisschen dieser Joker hin und her geschoben wird. Ja, wir können nicht so richtig, die Liberalen könnte ja eigentlich mal die SPD machen. Aber die SPD sagt, die sind doch sowieso jetzt in der Regierung, die Liberalen.
Es gibt da schon Bestrebungen, auch von unseren Seiten aus. Mein persönlicher letzter Stand ist, dass die niedersachsenische Landesspitze sich irgendwie an die CDU gewandt hat. Und die gesagt haben... Mein letzter Stand war, dass sich unsere Landesspitze an die CDU gewandt hat, die gesagt hat, ihr könntet das mal besser lassen, das ist Blödsinn. Und die CDU gesagt hat, wir finden das aber ganz toll, ihr könnt das mal.
Wir kennen die Problematik ja aus dem Bund genauso.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie gegen eine Wand laufen. Ich sage immer, konservative Betonköpfe, da ist manchmal echt wenig zu machen. Also es ist ein schwieriges Ding. Ich wünsche mir manchmal, dass dort vernünftige Leute in der CDU mal rangelassen werden. Also jetzt in der neuen Bundesregierung, vielleicht habt ihr nachher Lust, noch mal über das Thema Orketkommission zu sprechen. Da gibt es ja jetzt eine Kommission, die sich um diesen ganzen Themenbereich Netzpolitik kümmern soll.
Ja, die wird schon im nächsten Monat eingesetzt. Also das ist ja quasi jetzt schon beschlossen über alle Fraktionen hinweg.
Die Union hat jetzt zwei, drei sehr netzpolitisch kompetente Leute im Bundestag. Einer von denen, der heißt glaube ich irgendwie Kretschmer oder so. Der hat zwar eine konservative Meinung, aber der hat wenigstens Ahnung von dem, was er sagt.
Ja, hat ja seine Fraktion hinter sich. Das ist ja wohl nicht anzunehmen.
Da ist es so Usus, dass diejenigen, die jungen dabei sind, naja, die sollen sich erstmal einarbeiten. Die kriegen erstmal nichts zu sagen. Also da ist man dann mal so drauf, dass man sich freut, dass es dann mal Leute gibt, die von dem Thema, worüber sie reden, auch Ahnung haben. Aber dann haben die in der Fraktion nichts zu sagen, weil sie zu jungen dabei sind. Also daran scheitert es teilweise sogar. Also das ist irgendwie, ich muss sagen, ich bin in den letzten Monaten irgendwie mehr und mehr auf so eine Schiene gekommen, dass es mich einfach nur noch nervt, was so passiert.
Wie lange machst du denn schon politische Arbeit?
Oh man, das muss verdammt lange sein.
Ach mein Gott, ich bin 20, aber ich glaube, ich bin seit fünf Jahren bei den Julis und ich bin aktiv, ich glaube so 2006, 2007. Also aktiviert hat mich quasi der CCC deswegen. Ich habe irgendwie eure Kongresse von zu Hause aus verfolgt und habe damals noch TCPA und Facharbeiten drüber und Auswirkungen. Dieser ganze Gedöns hat mich dann auf diesen Netzpolitikbereich gebracht. Da bin ich dann dahin gekommen.
Da haben wir bei der Gelegenheit noch einen ziemlich coolen Tipp, denn wir veranstalten ja im Mai die SICKINT vom 22. und 24. Mai. Und ich glaube, die Netzsperren werden auch wieder Thema sein. Was Husi?
Ja, die Netzsperren werden ja Thema sein. Letztes Jahr hatten wir das ja eher so in Theorie. Und dieses Jahr machen wir das mal in der Praxis. Ich bringe so eine kleine Goldenshield Firewall mit und ein bisschen Equipment aus dem Iran. Und dann können wir das mal so richtig üben, wie das so geht. Wie das so in echt geht. Würdest du selber in China mit deinen Freunden zu Hause noch chatten können, irgendwie kannst du dann live ausprobieren. Das ist zumindest der Plan, aber das wird schon klappen. Ich bin ja guter Dinge.
Also es lohnt sich nach Köln zu fahren. Wer übrigens da mal klicken will, die URL, die ihr wissen wollt, ist sickint.ccc.de.
Das ist doch bestimmt doch alles im Wiki, oder? Im Wiki zur Sendung?
Was da jemand reinschreibt.
Ich weiß nicht, unser Moderator ist heute voll aufmüpfig, oder?
Tut mir total leid. Thomas, aber worauf ich noch mal hinaus wollte, ist, du machst das jetzt seit 4 Jahren. Wie viel Hoffnung hast du denn, also das klang jetzt ein bisschen an, auf Bundesebene ist schwierig, weil die jungen Leute kriegen halt nichts zu tun. Wie viel Hoffnung hast du denn generell, oder wie lange wird das dauern, bis Leute, die wenigstens Ahnung vom Netz haben, egal welche Meinung, bis die da in der Macht sind, oder sozusagen in die Strukturen kommen, wo sie was verändern können, oder wird das einfach nie mehr passieren?
Nein, nein, das wird passieren. Also das ist ganz klar. Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt mal überlege mal, auch ein Herr Bosbach war mal jung.
Also das glaube ich nun nicht.
Jung war er, ob er jung im Kopf war, das wissen wir mal drüber. Aber vom körperlichen her... Der wird mal jung gewesen sein, gehe ich doch mal von aus. Also das heißt, man wächst da rein. Wir haben jetzt langsam die Zeit, dass diejenigen, die sich mit diesen Themen wirklich auskennen und selbst durch den Faktor, dass sie genervt von der aktuellen Politik sind, sich der Sache zuwenden. Zumindest aus unserer Fraktion, da kenne ich die Leute halt direkt, da weiß ich, das sind teilweise Leute, die kommen aus dem IT-Bereich, die haben dort jahrelang gearbeitet und die haben selber diese Kopfschmerzen gehabt, die wir gerade haben und sagen sich irgendwie, das kann doch nicht sein, dass alles an der Realität vorbei regiert wird. Und wir sitzen mittlerweile für uns im Bundestag. Also da bin ich schon mal relativ froh. Deswegen bin ich auch ganz froh, dass es diese Enquete-Kommission gibt, dass zumindest aus fast allen Parteien kompetente Leute da drin sind.
Okay, also wir werden jetzt gleich mal über die Enquete-Kommission sprechen. Das Wort ist jetzt einmal zu oft gefallen. Aber trotzdem mal die Frage. Es ist so nochmal auf das Druckzeugen, was ich gerade gesagt habe. Es ist ja so in der Politik, da hat man zumindest den Eindruck, es werden die jungen Leuten protegiert, die den alten Leuten in den Kram passen. Und da ist ja Netzverständnis sozusagen nicht wirklich am Start mittlerweile. Meinst du nicht, es besteht die Gefahr, dass sozusagen das immer jetzt auch weiterhin die Leute, also in den Strukturen nach oben wandern, die halt sagen, diese konservative Einstellung zum Netz haben?
Also ich bin da ziemlich optimistisch, muss ich sagen. Weil zumindest in allen Parteien außer, ja ich sehe es zumindest in der CDU noch nicht aktiv, gibt es ja relativ starke Bewegungen, sich dieser Netzpolitik zu öffnen. Ganz egal jetzt in welchem Format und in welcher Breitbandigkeit das Ganze dann am Ende des Tages doch stattfindet, aber zumindest in allen anderen Parteien sieht man, dass es sich öffnet. Und da werden auch die langfristig nicht drumherum kommen, sich dahin gehen zu öffnen, um diesen Leuten irgendwie endlich mal Gehör zu geben.
Wie lange werden wir noch warten müssen? Letzte Frage.
Ach, wir warten nicht mehr, Markus.
Also, die sitzen schon im Bundestag. Die müssten nur noch...
Nee, sag einfach sozusagen, mir den Daumen gepeilt, in deine Glaskugel geguckt, eine Zahl.
Ende dieser Legislaturperiode, drei Jahre.
Alles klar. Dann haben wir Politiker, die vom Netz Ahnung haben und auch was sagen dürfen. Thomas, vielen Dank.
Ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen Abend.
Auf jeden Fall. Ich wäre jetzt also tatsächlich dafür, wenn jetzt nicht irgendwie die große Rebellion kommt, dass wir mal über diese komische Enquete... Wie heißt das richtig?
Die Enquete-Commission.
Weil es geht ja im Prinzip heute bei den drei Sachen, die wir besprechen, darum, wie geht Politik mit dem Netz um. Und das Positivste, was ich über diese Enquete-Position gehört habe, ist, dass es so eine Art Ausbildungslager für Politiker ist, damit sie irgendwie einen Format Plan haben. Jetzt... Oh Gott, muss ich mir überlegen. Wenn ich dich das überlege, kannst du... Constanze, du bist ja irgendwie mit dabei. Hat man gehört. Was ist das jetzt eigentlich?
Eine Enquete-Commission ist eigentlich eine Art Untersuchungskommission. Sie sollte sich also einem bestimmten Thema widmen und dazu über viele oder einige Monate, in diesem Fall sind es genau zwei Jahre, sich Meinung zu bestimmten vorher im Antrag festgelegten Themen bilden und das Ende dieser Enquete-Kommission bildet einen sogenannten Abschlussbericht. Das heißt, in diesem Fall besteht sie aus 37 Abgeordneten des Bundes und 37 technischen Sachverständigen in diesem Fall. Nicht alle technische Sachverständige, aber Sachverständige. Das heißt also, dass die paritätisch besetzt ist. Die fünf Fraktionen im Bundestag stellen also gemäß ihrer Zahlen im Bundestag dort diese 17 Abgeordneten und jeweils einer hat eine Sachverständigin. Ich bin einer von diesen. Und ungefähr die Hälfte der 17 Sachverständigen ist bis heute benannt worden. Einige Fraktionen haben sich da noch nicht eräußert. Aber es wird so sein, dass schon jetzt am Anfang April in der nächsten Sitzungswoche wird sich diese Enquete-Kommission konstituieren.
Und dann passiert die zwei Jahre was?
Man trifft sich dort meistens in der großen Runde, alle Vierteljahre. Aber es gibt auch noch Unterausschüsse. Und man wird die Themen, die vorher festgelegt sind, debattieren. Und das soll auch öffentlich sein. Das wird uns natürlich sehr freut.
Gibt es denn schon die Themen?
Ja klar, der Antrag ist auch ein letzter. Da kann man sich mal angucken. Es ist eine lange Liste. Es geht natürlich auch um geistige Eigentum. Es geht auch um Medienkompetenz. Also schon die Fragen, die wir hier besprochen haben. Es geht aber auch um sowas wie Green IT, E-Participation. Also schon netzpolitische Themen, die wir schon lange debattieren, aber im Fokus des Bundestags jetzt nicht eben standen.
Und was kommt da hinten raus?
Das Ende ist von so einer Enquete-Kommission. Das ist in der Regel ein Abschlussbericht. Wir hatten schon sehr interessante Enquete-Kommissionen. Das ist sehr häufig, etwa zur Frage der Ethik. Da ging es um Stammzellen und sowas. Es gibt auch in den Ländern eine Enquete-Kommission. Das ist schon nicht so häufig, dass sich der Bundestag zur Untersuchung eines bestimmten Themas so eine fraktionsübergreifende Kommission gibt.
Wen das interessiert, auf der deutschen Wikipedia gibt es da ausnahmsweise eine lange Liste mit all den Enquete-Kommissionen, die es in der Bundesrepublik noch gab. Wurde aus Relevanzgründen noch nicht gelöscht.
Also beeilt euch lieber.
Es ist natürlich so, dass die Fraktionen diese Enquete unterschiedlich sehen. Manche betrachten die als Alibi-Funktion. Wir wollen auch wirklich Interesse an dem Ergebnis zeigen. Aber nicht alle Fraktionen.
Am Ende wird halt ein Bericht stehen, und dieser Bericht soll der Regierung irgendwie Handlungsgrundlagen oder Empfehlungen geben, wie mit den einzelnen Themen umzugehen ist.
Und zwar möglichst mit Blick in die Zukunft, wenn man es mal so sagen will.
Aber die Geister scheiden sich halt noch an der Frage, ob das nur ein Knochen ist, den die Netzgemeinde jetzt hingeschmissen kriegt nach diesem ganzen Zensursula-Aufstand. Und das nur dazu da ist, um uns ruhig zu stellen, um uns das Gefühl zu geben, wir sind hier irgendwie ein bisschen vertreten. Die kümmern sich jetzt darum, die hören uns schon mal zu. Oder ob da wirklich was Sinnvolles bei rauskommt. Und naja, FIFA hat heute irgendwie gesagt, da ist so viel Sachverstand in der Kommission, das können die eigentlich gar nicht ernst meinen, dass sie das wirklich irgendwie sich daran halten, was dabei rauskommen könnte. Aber das müssen wir einfach mal abwarten.
Also am Ende ist es halt egal, wie die Parteien diese Ankerkommission sehen, wird es halt eine Eigendynamik entwickeln, eben weil das Netz halt da mit der Politik sehr unnütelbar konfrontiert ist und sehr unnütelbar zuguckt. Das heißt, es wird da eben die Netzöffentlichkeit halt dabei sein. Und das heißt, die Themen, die da jeweils diskutiert werden, werden dann halt eben im Netz auch weiter diskutiert. Und das ist halt der interessante Punkt, dass die jeweils diese Enquete-Sitzung dann Kondensationspunkte für die Diskussion um Themen sein werden, mit denen wir uns in der nächsten Zukunft halt irgendwie noch sehr intensiv auseinandersetzen müssen. Und selbst wenn die Enquete-Kommission an sich keinerlei Output hat, der irgendwie verwertbar ist, außer halt auf welche Berichte, ist es halt schon so, dass es für die Politik ein sehr wesentliches Signal ist, wie reagiert denn die Öffentlichkeit auf die Themen, die da gerade in der Enquete angesprochen werden.
Da sind sie von anderen Enquete nicht gewohnt, dass die Sitzung da so derart debattiert werden. Das wird aber hier so sein und wir haben auch als Sachverständige, die die schon bandant sind, auch beschlossen, dass wir über die Fraktionen hinweg auch zusammenarbeiten wollen. Also wir werden uns da nicht irgendwie so einer uninteressanten Parteitaktik hingeben. Uns geht es um die Sache.
Zur Verständnis, die Sachverständigen werden auch jeweils von den Parteien ernannt. Also quasi, man könnte im Prinzip jedem Sachverständigen eine Partei zuordnen.
Also bei mir persönlich ist es die Linksfraktion. Die hat zwei Abgeordneten. Und wir haben uns eigentlich mit allen Fraktionen des Bundestages, also wir jetzt als Chaos Computer Club unterhalten, und uns dann entschieden, das mit der Linkspartei zu machen. Aber es ändert sich absolut nichts daran, was wir da sachlich sagen werden.
Also sagen, und die Sieben, also beziehungsweise die Experten jetzt schon feststellen, die haben auf jeden Fall schon besprochen, dass ihr sozusagen euch nicht von der, welche Partei euch da berufen hat, sondern einfach sagen als Sachverständige dort.
Ja, also es wird da keine Beeinflussung auf parteipolitischer Ebene geben, sondern wir sind da als Sachverständige geraten, wenn wir unsere Sachverständigen Meinung abgeben.
Also spezifisch für die Sachverständigen, die halt eben aus der Netzgemeinde kommen, wäre es für die Parteien auch ziemlich blöd, wenn sie versuchen würden, die zu beeinflussen, weil das würde 30 Sekunden später auf dem Treter stehen und dann wäre sozusagen der Effekt halt hinüber. Also es ist halt so, dass da schon die Chance besteht, dass die Sachverständigen relativ unabhängig agieren können. Wie gesagt, inwieweit es halt irgendwie tatsächlich konkrete Ergebnisse gibt, da habe ich auch mal eine Zweifel, aber ich denke eben, dass die wesentliche Chance besteht halt darin, mal Flocke einzuschlagen und zu sagen, okay, hier haben wir den konzentrierten Sachverstand zu einem Thema abgefragt. Die Angriffskommission kann zum Beispiel auch Studien beauftragen, also sagen, okay, wir würden gerne mal zu diesem und jedem Thema mal gerne ein paar Zahlen haben.
Wir nehmen mal etwa die seltsamen Zahlen, die zum Firesharing so unterwegs sind. Also man könnte sich ja auch mal einen Überblick verschaffen und ein bisschen Versachlichung der Debatte. Und wir an CCC haben uns vorgenommen, die Enquete so zu benutzen, dass wir Konzepte, die wir haben, an die wir glauben, wo wir glauben, dass die einfach zukunftsträchtig sind, auch echt einbringen. Das werden wir auch tun, insbesondere zu Fragen des geistigen Eigentums.
Wie ist denn jetzt, was ich vorhin gesagt habe, so eine Art Ausbildungslager für Politiker, die Politiker, die da berufen wurden, ist es denn so, dass ihr, wenn ihr euch da zum ersten Mal zusammensetzt, dann gleich anfangen könnt zu reden oder muss dann erstmal sozusagen so eine Art Nachhilfeunterricht und Aufklärung betrieben werden?
Es ist natürlich klar, auf wen du anspielst. Der Vorsitzende dieser Enquete-Kommission ist Axel E. Fischer von der Union. Ja, wir haben den Hinweis schon verstanden. Und da ist es natürlich so, dass der sich in der letzten Woche unglaublich blamiert hat bei einem Interview im Deutschlandradio, der Deutschlandfunk war, glaube ich, breitband.
Das ist auch der, der keine Zeit fürs Internet hat, oder?
Ja, genau. Also da ist natürlich schon so, dass der Journalist ihnen einfach ein paar inhaltliche Fragen gestellt hat. Er ist der Vorsitzende dieser Kommission und er hat sich da sehr, ich muss mal sagen, blamiert. Denn er hat offenbar nicht mal die Fragen verstanden und hat dann aber auch nicht zugegeben, dass er von Begriffen wie Open Data, Liquid, Democracy überhaupt keine Idee hat, was das sein kann. Und hat sich damit so ein Politiker-Phrasen-Gedöns rausgerillt. Also ich muss schon sagen, selten wurde ein Politiker in Deutschland so vorgeführt. Das ist natürlich kein guter Beginn für die Enquete-Kommission.
Aber ich glaube, er selber hat es gar nicht gemerkt.
Natürlich hat er das gemerkt. Also ich denke, er wird schon einen Medienreferenten haben, der ihm gesagt hat, dass es vielleicht ein bisschen peinlich war.
Vielleicht hat es mir sein Berater hinterher gesagt. Das wäre ja auch schon mal was. Aber was ist denn sagen, okay, das ist Worst-Case-Szenario und gleich sehe ich noch den Vorsitzenden. Das ist ziemlich praktisch. Wie sieht es denn mit dem Rest aus?
Naja, wir kennen natürlich mittlerweile alle Abgeordneten, die sind bereits benannt. Das ist, muss ich sagen, schon sehr erfreulich, gerade von den Oppositionsparteien, dass da eben auch Leute drin sind, die sich wirklich für Netzpolitik interessieren. Also ich habe da jetzt nicht den Eindruck, dass von den kleinen Parteien insbesondere, dass da jetzt irgendwie Leute benannt wurden, die man nur gar nicht akzeptieren könnte. Natürlich gibt es ein Problem, insbesondere bei den Sozialdemokraten, Herr Dörrmann, der sich ja gerade bei den Netzsperren auch nicht gerade mit, naja wie soll man sagen, bekleckert hat mit Fachwissen. Also der Dörrmann ist natürlich für die Internetspolitische Community einfach ein roter Tuch.
Weil der ja bei den Netzperren damals sozusagen mitgeholfen hat.
Natürlich, der hat auch eine Rhetorik gefahren, die diffamierend war teilweise. Also da ist natürlich ein Problem, dass die SPD ihn benannt hat.
Ich schätze mal, das spiegelt sich dann halt auch genau wie in den anderen Fraktionen, da schon so ein bisschen die Balance zwischen denen, die es verstanden haben und der Hausmeisterfraktion, die halt irgendwie...
Man muss sehen, die SPD hat sich unmittelbar nach der Wahl von ihren eigenen Entscheidungen zum Zugangserschwerungsgesetz abgesetzt. Die SPD sagt, nein, wir wollen dieses Zugangserschwerungsgesetz nicht mehr, unmittelbar nach der Wahl. Aber sie haben denjenigen, der es am meisten protegiert hat, nämlich den Herrn Dörrmann, dennoch in diese Kommission benannt für Netzpolitik. Eigentlich ist das unerhört. Ich meine, es ist eigentlich sowieso ein sehr merkwürdiger Vorgang, den man in unserer bundesrepublikanischen Geschichte suchen darf. In meiner Meinung nach ist das nicht ein einziges Mal passiert, nämlich dass die ganz große Mehrheit ein Gesetz beschlossen hat, ein Zugangserschwerungsgesetz und dass unmittelbar nach der Wahl beide Parteien sagen, war nicht so eine gute Idee. Die SPD hat sich total abgesetzt. Unser damaliger Innenminister Schäuble hat gesagt, na, war ein bisschen Wahlkampf, haben wir nicht so gemeint. Das ist schon unglaublich peinlich, dass sie also zugeben, was das für ein Unverfolgerung ist.
Bei uns war es nicht nur ein bisschen Wahlkampf, er hat gesagt, es war eigentlich nur für den Wahlkampf, um die CDU von anderen Parteien abzusetzen und es gab handwerkliche Fehler.
Da muss man schon sagen, da kann man den Glauben an die parlamentarische Demokratie schon verlieren, wenn die also selber eingestehen, was sie da von technischem Unverstand haben.
Da würde ich gerne noch mal eure Meinung zu einem kleinen Punkt haben. Es war ja so, dass zum Schluss irgendwie alle gesagt haben, also Netzperngesetz, ja nicht so eine geile Idee, aber Bundespräsident unterschreibt mal bitte trotzdem. Warum ist das passiert?
Es ist eine Frage der Gesichtswahrung am Ende. Sie haben ja auf die inhaltlichen Fragen des Bundespräsidialamts nicht geantwortet. Es ging ja vor allen Dingen in den Fragen, die der Bundespräsident gestellt hat an das Parlament, auch nochmal darum, ob es wirklich verfassungsgemäß war. Da gibt es ja eine Menge Fragen, geostische Fragen. Und es ist so, dass die einfach gar nicht geantwortet haben auf diese Frage. Sie mussten diese unangenehme, wie haben wir sie genannt, Gesetzesleiche, sie mussten ja irgendetwas machen, sie mussten in Kraft treten. Also es hat passiert und dann hat sich das Bundesinnenministerium entschieden, diesen Nichtanwendungserlass zu machen. Das heißt, ein, zwei Tage später wurde beschlossen, es wird nicht angewandt. Und geht natürlich den Willen des Parlamentes. Aber es gibt gerade keine Partei im Bundestag.
Okay, sagen wir nochmal, nur zu meinem Verständnis auch. Also es gibt jetzt ein Gesetz, das hat unsere Legislative, also die gesetzgebende, Mit großer Mehrheit? Der gesetzgebende Teil des Staates sozusagen beschlossen. Das ist vom Bundespräsident entschieden.
Ausgefertigt?
Das heißt. Unterschrieben worden. So und jetzt hat eine ausführende Behörde, das ist dann die Exekutive, wenn ich im Gemeinschaftskundeunterricht richtig aufgehört habe, hat gesagt so, nee, machen wir aber nicht. Jetzt ist es so, wir sind jetzt nicht so richtig böse wahrscheinlich, weil das Gesetz passt uns den Kram, aber hä?
Es findet sich vor allen Dingen auch keine Oppositionspartei, die jetzt gegen diesen Nichtanwendungserlass vorgehen würde.
Obwohl das verfassungsrechtlich fast noch bedenklicher ist.
Ja, denn niemand will jetzt sagen, hey, ja, wir wollen doch, dass es angewendet wird. Und wir haben dann ein Problem erkannt, was uns in dieser Konstellation noch nie begegnet ist. Nämlich die Frage der Verfassungsbeschwerde. Dieses Gesetz ist ja in Kraft und im Prinzip könnten sich jetzt verschiedene Initiativen, die die Verfassungsbeschwerden dagegen ja auch bereits vorbereiten, nach Karlsruhe wenden. Das können sie aber nicht, denn der Nichtanwendungserlass hat genau diese Frist, die man haben kann, wenn man in Karlsruhe Beschwerde einlegt. Also ein Jahr.
Du hast ein Jahr Zeit, um in Karlsruhe zu klagen, aber du kannst nur klagen oder Beschwerde einlegen. Du kannst aber das nur machen, wenn das Gesetz in Kraft ist. Ausgefertigt, das ist es inzwischen. Aber es muss auch angewendet werden. Und das wird es nicht für das nächste Jahr. Und deswegen kann sich das auch noch...
Du brauchst einen konkreten Betroffenen. Das heißt, du musst in der Verfassungsbeschwerde genau beschreiben, welche oder welcher, können eine oder mehrere Personen sein, direkt von so einem Gesetz betroffen sind. Das kann natürlich nicht passieren, solange es nicht angewendet wird. Das heißt, hier hat sich die BMI auch gleich noch hintenrum eine Methode ausgesagt, um wirkungsvoll eine Verfassungsbeschwerde, die mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit recht peinlich ausgeht, für die Regierung auszuheben. Ich denke, da müssen wir auch nochmal mit Juristen reden.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das hört sich jetzt so nach einer Art Loch an.
Das ist ein Hack, würde ich sagen. Das ist ein Hack.
Okay, das heißt, ihr seid gerade von der Regierung geowned?
Ne, die Regierung hat ihr parlamentarisches System geowned.
Das BMI gehört ja zur Regierung, wenn man so rumzählen will.
Naja, aber wir haben trotzdem den Punkt, dass möglicherweise in einem Jahr ein Gesetz in Kraft wird und dann nicht mehr Verfassungsbeschwerde eingelegt werden kann, weil, also das heißt, es ist ja dann...
Wenn man es sich so klassisch vorstellen will, dann läuft da halt so ein Zombie durch den Reißdach.
Naja, der Punkt ist natürlich auch dran, das muss man sich mal ein bisschen überlegen. Die Zeit dieses Nichtanwendungserlasses soll ja auch genutzt werden für eine gewisse Evaluation. Die findet auch derzeit schon statt. BKA weist etwa schon Zahlen vor für Januar und Februar. Also wo waren Seiten, die gemeldet wurden, konnten die gelöscht werden und so weiter. Aber natürlich können sie nicht tatsächlich evaluieren, wie eine Sperrliste gewirkt hat. Denn es gibt ja keine Sperrliste. Also die ganze Evaluierung hat natürlich diesen Pferdefuß, dass nur ein ganz kleiner Teil dieses Gesetzes evaluiert werden kann, nämlich die Frage, was gelöscht werden kann. Und im Übrigen...
Also ganz ehrlich, ich habe jetzt den Faden verloren. Also weil der Punkt ist, ich habe den Eindruck, man macht so eine politische Entscheidung einfach beliebig kompliziert und irgendwann haben die Leute dann keinen Bock mehr.
Das ist doch überhaupt nicht kompliziert.
Na gut, aber das Kernprinzip hast du schon ganz klar erkannt. Also es ist halt so, dass Hex-Überkomplexität sind in der Politik immer üblicher und je finsterer so ein Skandal ist, desto komplexer muss man ihn machen.
Damit niemand mehr mitkriegt, um was es eigentlich geht.
Ich würde sagen, wir führen das nach den Nachrichten weiter. Vorher wollte ich noch eine ganz einfachen Frage widmen, die wir heute in der Sendung gestellt haben. Das ist nämlich die Frage Jungen-Media-Schutz-Stars-Vertrag. Da geht es ja darum, dass man Inhalte labelt, sagt ab 18. Das heißt, es dürfte dann erst ab 22 Uhr im Internet gesendet werden. Unsere Frage war, wie spät ist es eigentlich im Internet? Robert hat vielleicht eine Antwort. Hallo Robert.
Hi, wie spät ist es im Internet?
Schöne Sendung, übrigens wollte ich sagen. Und ich bin auch ein großer Fan von Erich Kessner. Da sollte ich noch loswerden.
Sind wir das nicht alle?
Wie spät ist es im Internet?
Wie spät ist es im Internet? Also ich würde sagen, für jede Kommunikation gibt es ja eine Absenderadresse. Und ich sage mal, eine Werbung mit dieser Absenderadresse funktioniert ja mittlerweile auch sehr gut. Gerade was Social Networks angeht, da wird ja mal Werbung eingeblendet über den Ursprungsort des Absenders. Im Grunde genommen könnte eine Webseite auf diesen Verfahren aufbauen und genauso prüfen, wie spät ist es bei dieser Absenderadresse im Grunde genommen. Und das Einzige, was denen noch entgegensprechen würde, wäre diese Benutzung von anonymes Proxys oder hier von der TU.
Ich wollte dich gerade fragen. Also ich surf normalerweise nicht mit einer deutschen IP-Adresse. Keine Ahnung, wie das bei dir ist.
Okay, ich bin da noch sehr ehrlich unterwegs, muss ich sagen.
Ich hätte gerne jetzt eine Frage an die Fachleute. Wie lange dauert es, mir ein Programm zu schreiben, das meine IP ständig in eine Geolocation wechselt, wo es immer 22.03 Uhr ist?
Da brauchst du doch kein Programm für.
Das ist ziemlich trivial.
Aber ich sag mal, das ist nicht trivial, aber im Grunde genommen wäre die Möglichkeit, solche Anonymus-Proxys abzugrenzen oder auszugrenzen, oder deren Benutzung einfach zu unterbinden, die Möglichkeit, solche zeitlichen Beschränkungen einzuführen.
Na ja, also ich meine, wenn du erst mal alles so eingrenzen und begrenzen kannst, praktisch so eine chinesische Internetmauer hast, dann brauchst du auch keine Sendezeitbegrenzung mehr. Weil dann hast du ganz andere Möglichkeiten, da Dinge zu begrenzen.
Okay gut, das sind die Rollstuhlfahnen und Politiker, die jetzt in andere Forts abgewandert sind, die das Ganze ins Rollen gebracht haben. Ich sag mal, das geht natürlich nur, wenn man es auch weiterdenkt. Ich bin ja auf eurer Seite, aber rein theoretisch ist das ja durchaus möglich. Und wenn man schon über solche Sperren redet, dann redet man wahrscheinlich auch über anonyme Benutzung, die ja dann wahrscheinlich eh fallen wird im Laufe dieser Zeit.
Ich finde es interessant, die Frage, also ich hatte nur die Gelegenheit, die Frage mit dem neuen Innenminister Thomas de Maizière zu debattieren. Also ob es überhaupt eine Frage, oder ob es überhaupt ein Recht auf Anonymität im Netz noch gibt.
Ja, also ich sag mal, man beschränkt in alle Richtungen. Also im Grunde genommen wäre es nur konsequent, diese Anonymität auch aufzuheben. Und das erste wäre natürlich, solche anonymen Proxies zu verbieten. Um Gottes Willen, ich hasse diese Netzsperrengeschichte. Ich bin wie gesagt großer Fan von Erich Kessner. Und der Treffner hätte man das nicht formulieren können. Im Grunde genommen geht es um Aufklärung und nicht um Vertuschungen. Also meine Meinung.
Glaubst du, dass die Debatte um darum eigentlich irgendwas genützt hat, für die Frage der Bilder und Filme von Kindesmissbrauch? Also wie siehst du überhaupt so diese Debatte, in Bezug auf das Problem, was eigentlich gelöst werden sollte?
Das ist eine Frage, der in Beantwortung, wie ich sicher weiß, mehrere Minuten dauern wird. Das wiederum bedeutet, Robert muss jetzt noch so lange gedulden, bis Nachrichtenwörter und Verkehr vorbei sind, weil dann machen wir damit weiter. Nachrichten. Mit Mario Bartsch.
Zu den Terroranschlägen von Moskau haben sich islamistische Rebellen aus dem Nordkaukasus bekannt. Ihr Anführer erklärte in einem Internet-Video, die Anschläge seien ein Racheakt dafür, dass russische Sicherheitskräfte Zivilisten getötet hätten. Der Rebellenführer kündigte weitere Anschläge an. Zwei Selbstmordattentäterinnen hatten in der Moskau Metro am Montag 39 Menschen mit in den Tod gerissen. Bei zwei weiteren Selbstmordanschlägen wurden heute mindestens 12 Menschen in der südrussischen Provinz Dagestan getötet. Die internationale Staatengemeinschaft stellt Haiti für den Wiederaufbau nach dem Erdbeben vor zweieinhalb Monaten mehrere Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung. Das ist das Ergebnis einer Geberkonferenz der Vereinten Nationen in New York. Das meiste Geld versprach Venezuela mit umgerechnet 1, 6 Milliarden Euro. Große Geldsummen sagten auch die EU und die USA zu. Bei dem Beben waren in Haiti rund 230.000 Menschen ums Leben gekommen und Hunderttausende obdachlos geworden. Zur Enttäuschung von Umweltschützern hat US-Präsident Obama Teile der US-Küste für Öl- und Gasbohrungen freigegeben. Sie seien notwendig, um den amerikanischen Energiebedarf zu decken und Arbeitsplätze zu sichern, sagte Obama. Er wolle auch alternativere Energien weiter fördern. Betroffen sind die Ostküste am Atlantik und die Südküste am Golf von Mexiko. Im Basketball-Eurocup hat Alba Berlin als erste deutsche Mannschaft überhaupt die Final-Vorrunde erreicht. Die Berliner besiegten im Viertelfinal-Rückspiel Jerusalem mit 72 zu 59 und machten damit die 61 zu 67 Niederlage aus dem Hinspielbett. Heute Nacht gibt es ein paar Wolken, aber meist bleibt es trocken. Die Tieftemperaturen liegen um 1 Grad. Am Tag dann maximal 12 Grad. Zunächst ist das längere Zeit heiter. Später gibt es häufiger Wolken und vor allem in Richtung Prägnitz und Hafenland auch Regen oder Graupelschauer. A2 Berlin Richtung Magdeburg. Zwischen Ciesa und Thesen liegen Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn. Da handelt es hier wohl um Reifenteilefahrt entsprechend vorsichtig. A9 Berlin Richtung Halle Leipzig. Zwischen Belitz-Hallstetten und Belitz gibt es Bergungsarbeiten nach einem Unfall. Die rechte Spur ist da gesperrt, benutzt die linke Spur. A10 westlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Dreieckhafenland. Zwischen Potsdam Nord und Spandau gibt es auch eine Sperrung. Und zwar der Richtungsfahrbahn wegen Bergungsarbeiten nach einem Unfall. A11 Pumeln Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Joachimsthal und Korinne gab es einen Unfall. Dort ist die rechte Spur gesperrt. Und A12 Berlin Richtung Frankfurt Oder. Zwischen Storkow und Fürstenwalde West gab es einen Unfall mit einem Lkw. Dort ist die rechte Spur blockiert. Sonst überall gute Fernsehen.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2?
Chaos Radio, mit konstant so kurzen Scusi und wohin verschwindet Frank Rieger eigentlich immer während der Nachrichten?
Zum Kaffeeautomaten.
Äh, koffeinsüchtig, so sind sie. Die Leute vom Chaos Computer Club, die hier jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat reinkommen und über Techniksachen, so im weitesten Sinne könnte man sagen, mit euch und uns reden.
Das machen wir jetzt in einer Beschreibung, oder? Was macht ihr im Chaos Radio Techniksachen?
Ja, also ich mein, ist aber sozusagen das Wort, was tatsächlich alle Leute verstehen. Was macht ihr da im Radio? Ja, so Technik.
Der Kaffee ist gex, der Frank ist wieder da.
Hey, welcome back! So, es geht heute um Netzsperren. Um ACTA. Ein Geheimvertrag. James Bond ist ja ein Geheimvertrag, der dazu dienen soll, dass man eure iPods durchsuchen kann, wenn ihr fliegt. Und um einen Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrag, der dafür sorgen soll, dass das Internet ganz sauber wird. Und wir haben gerade mit Robert gesprochen, welcome back auch. Und Konz hat eine Frage an dich.
Ach, eigentlich ist mir jetzt eine andere eingefallen.
Immer her damit.
Kann ich die vielleicht trotzdem mal stellen? Wir hatten ja vorhin irgendwie diese Debatte. Was steht eigentlich dahinter? Was ist die große Idee hinter dieser Säuberungsaktion und dieser Internetregulierung? Was ist eigentlich deine Meinung dazu?
Also ich sag mal so, ich denke schon, und das kommt eben aus der Rollstuhlzeit, ich denke mal schon, dass es einfach um die totale Kontrolle geht. Letztendlich ist alles, was der Staat an Daten bekommt, für ihn irgendwo wertvoll bezüglich irgendwelcher Raster, die er fahndet oder bezüglich irgendwelcher Auswertungen, wo ist noch mehr Geld rauszuholen, wo gibt es Steuersünder, die ich auf diesem Wege vielleicht erwische. Also ich denke mal, es geht dem Staat einfach um totale Kontrolle. Und um nichts weiter. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass... Also ich sag mal, die Effizienz dieser Maßnahmen ist, glaube ich, die tendiert gegen Null, weil Kriminalität sucht sich immer ihre Wege. Und letztendlich weicht die einfach nur aus. Also ich sag mal, da gibt es keinen Druck, sondern es gibt einfach nur ein Ausweichen. Und das sucht neue Wege. Und deswegen kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass es darum alleine geht. Sondern ich denke mal eher, dass es um die totale Kontrolle geht.
Also das heißt, wir haben ja jetzt eigentlich mit den Netzsperren eine andere Debatte, als bei dieser angeblichen Sicherheit, die uns andere Sätze versprechen. Es geht ja darum, dass du was nicht sehen darfst. Es geht dir darum, quasi so eine Art sauber Internet für die erste Welt zu etablieren. Oder vielleicht noch die erste Welt und Teile der Entwicklungssender noch dazu. Wenn man jetzt mal ACTA dazu nimmt, dann ist es ja eine größere Gruppe.
Also ich sag mal so, die Netzschwere ist vielleicht nur die Spitze des Eisbergs. Im Grunde genommen, wenn ihr, und ich hab der Sendung ein bisschen zuhören können, wenn man über ACTA redet, dann geht das ja viel mehr in die Tiefe, sag ich mal. Und im Endeffekt ist das wahrscheinlich, also ich sag mal, die Netzschwere ist eher populistisch. Und der Rest ist wahrscheinlich eher das Kontrollorgan, was da hinter geschlossenen Vorhängen verhandelt.
Also bei ACTA würde ich aber sagen, dass es hauptsächlich um irgendwie Gewinne geht. Da geht es um Geld, da geht es um richtig dick Geld.
Nee, es geht immer um Geld. Also ich mein, hey, da kannst du immer das Argument bringen.
Also ich denke, dass der Hintergrund schon ist, dass es da um eine Disziplinierung geht. Also sowohl was die Inhalte angeht, als auch was den Umgang mit geistigen Eigentum und ähnlichen Dingen angeht. Dass den alten Herren, die uns da momentan noch regieren, die wollen zwar gern, dass wir die Chancen des Internets, also diese ganze bunte Geschichte damit handeln und so. Das wird das alles nutzen, aber auf der einen Seite uns natürlich irgendwie gegen die Chinesen abgrenzen können, sowohl sicherheitsmäßig als auch was irgendwie die Sicherheit des geistigen Eigentums angeht, als auch dafür sorgen, dass in den kommenden Krisen das Internet ihnen nicht der Kontrolle entleitet. Und die momentane Struktur, die da ist, wird da in diesen Kreisen als irgendwie nicht krisenfähig angesehen. Und das ist denke ich mal der Hintergrund dessen von all diesen Maßnahmen, dass sie sich da allmählich so ein Set von Dingen zusammenbauen, mit denen sie glauben, die Kontrolle behalten zu können, wenn es hier mal ein bisschen weniger lustig wird.
Richtig, ja. Klingt plausibel auf jeden Fall, keine Frage. Ich denke nur, wenn man sich solche technischen Möglichkeiten etabliert, bleibt es bei dieser Nutzung oder geht es einfach weiter? Also ich sage mal, das ist genau die gleiche Geschichte mit den Mautstellen. Ich habe damals schon überlegt, warum nicht auch den Fahrer fotografieren? Warum fotografiert man nur das Kennzeichen? Im Grunde genommen fotografiert man mit Sicherheit auch den Fahrer. Dann macht man eine Gesichtsfelderkennung und schon hat man noch perfektere Bewegungsdaten als vielleicht mit einer triangulären Ortung über das Handy, was er da mit sich führt.
Zumindest im deutschen Mautsystem werden die Fahrer üblicherweise mitfotografiert.
Richtig, genau. Aber Baden-Württemberg war glaube ich das erste Land, das das mal öffentlich gemacht hat. Ich meine, es gab da mal eine Diskussion, dass es eben nicht gemacht wird.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, die Nutzung der Möglichkeiten.
Der verweist es gut. Wie war es denn bisher mit neuen Technologien und Möglichkeiten? Und wie wurden sie bisher genutzt? Und bisher wurden sie meistens dann ausgebaut, nachträglich. Und es wurde hinterher irgendwie Dinge auch anders genutzt als sie.
Wir haben natürlich auch schon gesehen, wer der Interesse hat. Wir haben eine Debatte gehabt über unerlaubte Glücksspiele. Natürlich über die Fragen von urheberrechtlich geschützten Werken. Wir haben über Nazi-Seiten, also alles das kam ja im Wahlkampf schon hoch.
Ein gutes Beispiel, um da nochmal zurückzukommen, das geht jetzt auch wieder zurück auf die Netzsperren, ein super Beispiel ist Italien. Italien hat 2006 angefangen, so genannte kinderpornografische Seiten zu sperren. Das gleiche Spiel, was Zensursula gebracht hat, das gleiche Spiel, was die Malmström jetzt bringt, das war in Italien 2006. Haben sie gesagt, nee, es geht wirklich nur um solche Sachen, wir grenzen das ein, das wird für nichts anderes benutzt, haben sie angefangen, ein paar hundert Seiten zu sperren. Dann, das nächste, was kam, war Glücksspiel. In Italien ist das ähnlich wie in Deutschland, staatliches Glücksspielmonopol. Also haben sie 536 Glücksspielseiten gesperrt. Das war 2008 oder so. Inzwischen gibt es halt Gerichtsurteile durch die, wie hast du gesagt Frank, Content-Mafia?
Die Musik- und Filmindustrie, ich darf mal noch mal was setzen hier.
Die über italienische Gerichte erreicht haben, dass The Pirate Bay auf diese Sperrfilter gesetzt wird. Und jetzt wird The Pirate Bay in Italien gesperrt. Malta leidet auch drunter, weil die Ablinks von Malta des Internet-Backbounds laufen über Italien. Das heißt, die Leute in Malta haben jetzt auch kein Pirate Bay mehr, obwohl die da gar nichts mit zu tun haben erstmal.
Da kommen wir noch mal zu einem wichtigen Punkt.
Das ist doch ein super Beispiel, wie es läuft. Es wird genauso laufen wie in Italien.
Das ist aber nur wirtschaftlich, sage ich mal. Was ich zum Beispiel bezüglich dieser SWIFT-Diskussion, Amerikaner wollen unsere Bankdaten haben.
Okay, Robert, vielen Dank, aber du tendierst dazu, sozusagen abzuweichen. Und wir haben noch den Martin in der Leitung. Der hat nämlich eine Frage zu den Netzfiltern. Und in diesem Fall, ich weiß nicht, ob man das sozusagen politisch zu sehen sollte, aber Netzfilter schlägt Zwift. Zumindest heute Abend. Aber vielen Dank. So, dann haben wir nämlich den Martin hier. Martin, hi.
Hallöchen, guten Abend.
Wo ist deine Frage zu den Netzfiltern?
Ja, unter anderem. Ja, ich hatte vorhin, ihr habt kurz von der Detektierbarkeit gesprochen, der Filter oder dieser Filterlisten. Das würde mich prinzipiell interessieren, wie das funktioniert, aber das müsst ihr vielleicht nicht in der Sendung klären, wenn ihr das im Nachhinein verlinken könnt oder so.
Nein, im Prinzip ist das ganz einfach. Ich erkläre es mal kurz für DNS-Sperren, für das, was Frau van der Leyen da so vorgeschlagen hat und das, was auch bei der Frau Malström anscheinend so im... Also die hat das ja nicht so definiert, aber... Also für DNS ist es ganz einfach. Wenn ich im Internet-Server und in meinem Browser eingebe www.ccc.de, dann geht mein Rechner daher zu einem DNS-Server, fragt den du www.ccc.de, was ist denn das für eine IP? Der DNS-Server gibt mir die IP zurück, mein Rechner macht eine Verbindung zu dieser IP auf Pod 80 auf, und ich sehe die Webseite.
Eigentlich einfach so weit so gut.
So weit so gut, so funktioniert das normalerweise. Wenn man jetzt DNS-Filterung macht, dann wird der DNS-Server vom Provider so manipuliert, dass er dir nicht mehr die Wahrheit sagt, sondern dich anlügt.
Und zwar haben sie dafür übrigens einen schönen Namen, nämlich Government Enhanced Response.
Also in China heißt das irgendwie, wie nennen sie das mit der Zensur in China?
Irgendeinen euphämistischen Namen, wenn sie schon haben, Great Wall?
Nein, sie harmonisieren das Internet. Also bei so einer DNS-Sperre läuft das dann so, dein Rechner fragt den DNS-Server www.ccc.de, welcher IP-Nummer ist das? Und der DNS sagt dir nicht mehr die echte IP-Nummer vom CCC, sondern sagt dir irgendeine andere IP-Nummer von einer Webseite, wo diese bekannte Stop-Seite draufliegt. Dein Rechner macht darauf hin, im Glauben zum CCC zu gehen, dorthin eine Verbindung auf und du siehst diese Stop-Seite. So funktioniert es. Und naja, wie man es detektiert, ist doch ganz einfach irgendwie. Du suchst ja zwei DNS-Server auf der Welt, einer, der vielleicht lügt und einer, der garantiert nicht lügt.
Wobei du einfach herausfinden kannst, welcher lügt, denn das sind ja definierte in Deutschland, die einen müssen.
Und dann testest du einfach www.ccc.de, fragst den einen, fragst den anderen. Man kennt ja das alte Sprichwort, Lügen haben kurze Beine. Das gilt auch im Internet. Du wirst ziemlich schnell herausfinden, welche DNS-Server dir welchen Quatsch erzählen und welche nicht. Und sie können dagegen nichts tun. Weil wenn sie aufhören, uns irgendwie die Filterlisten detektierbar zu machen, dann hören sie auf zu filtern. Also ich meine, deswegen haben Filterlisten, vor allem diese angeblich geheimen Filterlisten, den inherenten Schaden, dass sie den größten möglichen Gau, nämlich dass die Listen an interessierte Pädophile liegen, die dann so eine Art gelbe Seiten für umsonst auf Steuergelder erstellt bekommen haben, dass genau das nicht zu verhindern ist. Es ist inherent in dieser Technologie. Es geht gar nicht ohne. Und im Prinzip ist das für Hybridsperren und alles andere, was da diskutiert wird, genauso.
Hybrid was?
Hybridsperren.
Naja, wir sollten darüber mal sprechen, da das Innenministerium derzeit sagt, Hybridsperren wären vielleicht für ein neues Zugangserschwerungsgesetz eine Idee. Die wollte daran festhalten.
Ja, das macht es auch nicht unmöglich.
Was sind denn die Hybridsperren?
Also Hybridsperren funktionieren so, dass ich nicht mehr die DNS manipuliere, die DNS-Server, die dann mir eine falsche IP zurückgeben, sondern ich definiere erst mal, was ich sperren will. Also ich sage, ich will den CCC sperren, der hat eine IP-Nummer. Oder vielleicht auch ein ganzes.
So ein garartgeheimer Wunsch von dir?
Nee, nee, das gibt es wirklich. Das wird in England gemacht. Das Clean-Feed-Programm aus Großbritannien funktioniert genau nach diesem Prinzip. Das in Australien diskutierte Zensursystem funktioniert auch genau nach diesem Prinzip. Was man macht, ist, man erstellt erst mal eine Liste von IP-Nummern oder IP-Ranges, wo Sachen liegen, die man ausfiltern möchte, ohne die genau zu spezifizieren. Und dann tut man in einem ersten Schritt, allen Datenverkehr, der zu diesen IP-Ranges oder zu diesen IPs geht, über eine andere Route führen. Den führt man nicht daraus ins Internet, wo es normalerweise rausgeht, sondern den führt man auf eine Seitenstraße. Dort steht ein transparenter Proxy oder ein System, wo der Datenverkehr durchläuft. Und dieses System guckt sich den Datenverkehr ganz genau an. Und schaut dann, ah, du willst zu YouTube. Wohin willst du denn zu YouTube? Welches Video guckst du dir an? Ah, das Video, wo Kemal Atatürk beleidigt wird. Ne, das zeigen wir dir nicht. Und dieser zweite Schritt, das zeigen wir dir nicht. Das funktioniert dann in diesem System, was den Datenverkehr anguckt genau. Und dann ganz individuell auf einzelne Bilder oder auf einzelne Webseiten sagen kann, das darfst du nicht sehen.
Der Unterschied ist also...
Die können dann machen, dass du Spiegel.de noch lesen kannst, aber das Bild, was zu dem Artikel da steht, das siehst du nicht mehr.
Der Unterschied ist also genau der, der zwischen dem Gesetz bei uns und etwa der Lösung aus Australien und Großbritannien, die es Gusi eben nannte. Bei uns haben wir nur voll qualifizierte Domain-Namen. Das heißt, die gesamte Domain wird gesperrt oder nichts. Und hier ist es halt spezifischer, das führt aber auch dazu, dass das Overblocking, das sogenannte Overblocking, geringer wird. Dass man also nicht so sehr viel mit sperrt, weil es eben im selben Domain ist.
Sondern nur das sperrt, was quasi direkt auf der Liste steht.
Es ist viel aufwendiger, viel teurer, kann man genauso schnell und einfach umgehen. Man muss es ein bisschen anders machen, wie bei DNS, aber es geht genauso. Und es ist auch nicht viel schwieriger. Und was auch zu beachten ist, sämtlicher Verkehr von allen Leuten, die zum Beispiel zu YouTube surfen, wenn man bei dem Beispiel von eben bleiben, der hier Datenverkehr wird ganz genau analysiert. Da wird ganz genau erfasst, welches Video guckst du dir an, wie oft hast du draufgeklickt, hast du einen Kommentar hinterlassen, was stand in dem Kommentar drinnen. Und das betrifft alle Leute, die in einen Server oder wie zum Beispiel YouTube unsurfen, wo nur ein Film gesperrt wird. Aber alle Leute, die zu YouTube gehen, egal was sie sich angucken, werden durch den Filter durchlaufen und ihre Daten werden erfasst, ausgewertet und so weiter. Und so ein System ist natürlich der perfekte Einstieg zur Zensur. Und so machen also das Prinzip wird ja in China mitunter auch angewendet. Ja, du siehst dann die Ergebnisse und alles in den News. Aber sobald du auf die Seite klickst, ist der Artikel bei Spiegel über 1989 und Platz des himmlischen Friedens und so nicht mehr vorhanden.
Also was man damit machen kann, ist halt so granular, dass man damit zum Beispiel auch einzelne Google-Suchergebnisse rausfüttern kann aus Seiten. Also man kann halt da auch Pattern-Matching machen, das noch sehr viel genauer ist, bis runter zu einzelnen Kommentaren in Blogs oder ähnlichem. Das ist so die ungeahnte Möglichkeit. Die Zensur kann da, also wenn diese Technologie einmal installiert ist, kann die halt eben genau so granular funktionieren, dass sie halt auch sehr schwer zu bemerken ist. Das ist während es ja sonst so ist, wenn eine komplette Domain nicht erreichbar ist, wenn wir plötzlich YouTube nicht erreichen können, würden es die meisten Leute wohl doch irgendwie mitbekommen.
Wenn halt auf YouTube ein Video nicht mehr zu sehen und anzuklicken ist, dann merken das die meisten Leute nicht direkt. Alles andere scheint ja zu gehen.
Also ich finde es ganz interessant, dass wir jetzt wie selbstverständlich so ein bisschen auf China oder Iran als Beispiel für die, die ganz schlimm machen gekommen sind. Denn ich glaube der Punkt ist hier auch, dass wir uns da Fragen danach stellen müssen, wie unsere Demokratie funktioniert. Ja, was ist das Modell? Und zur Zeit ist dieses Streben so richtig, selbst bei Stab Richtung China, ja, wir regulieren das immer stärker. Natürlich weisen jetzt alle diesen Zensurvorwurf von sich, ja. Klar, weil auch niemand irgendwie bei diesen Bildern oder Filmen die Kindesmissbrauch zeigen, an Zensur denkt, das will ja niemand haben. Aber dass natürlich die...
Die selben technischen Möglichkeiten verwendet werden können, um ganz andere Sachen zu filtern, das ist das eigentliche Problem, worum es hier geht. Und deswegen darf man nie ein System installieren, was diesem technischen Möglichkeiten bietet. Zumindest nicht in einer demokratischen offenen Gesellschaft, für die sich Europa hält oder die sie sein möchte. Zumindest habe ich das so mitgekriegt.
Mit der Argumentation könnte man auch sagen, die Polizisten dürfen keine Schusswaffen mehr tragen, weil damit könnten sie auch Unschuldige erschießen.
Am Ende ist es ja eine Frage der Abwägung. Die Meinungsfreiheit bedeutet ja, dass du das Recht hast, etwas zu sagen, auch wenn es jemand anderes nicht passt. Und die Diskussion darüber, was wir an Inhalten als Gesellschaft nicht haben wollen, was wir als Gesellschaft, was wir gerade in Deutschland spezifisch, doch eher etwas unfallreicher historisch bedingt. Und die Mechanismen, wie diese sozusagen zustande kommt, dafür gibt es ja tatsächlich Gerichte und dergleichen Dinge mehr.
Rechtsstaatliche Regeln, ja.
Also tatsächlich rechtsstaatliche Regeln. Und wenn wir uns als Gesellschaft darauf einigen, dass bestimmte Inhalte illegal sind, dann sollen sie bitte auch bestraft werden. Das heißt, dann soll die Verbreitung und Produktion dieser Inhalte bestraft werden.
Das heißt löschen auch.
Und halt auch ausfindig machen der Leute, die es tun. Und das ist der einzige Weg, der funktioniert. Wir können nicht sagen, wir als Gesellschaft einigen uns jetzt mal darauf, dass da irgendeine obskure Kommission hingeht, dass wir bestimmte Sachen nicht sehen sollen, wenn wir nicht wissen, wie man daran kommt. Das ist völlig unwürdig.
Ich meine, es soll trotzdem, wir wissen, dass technisch detektierbar ist, immer noch eine geheime Sperre zu sein. Das heißt, derjenige wird auch nicht informiert. Die Listen werden quasi an die großen Provider und natürlich auch noch an die Unis und andere große Institutionen weitergegeben, damit die umgesetzt werden für die Sperrinfrastruktur. Aber der Betroffene, der soll nicht mal informiert werden. Das ist irgendwie ein sehr merkwürdiges Konstrukt, das rechtsstaatliche Standards vermissen lässt.
Vielen Dank, Martin. Auf jeden Fall haben wir noch mal die Netzfilter von vorne nach hinten aufgerollt.
Oh, wir haben vergessen, dass noch Martin da war.
Kann ich noch mal ganz kurz?
Ich bin zum Beispiel ein Supporter beim Online-Game-Spiel. Ich will das Spiel nicht nennen, das ist egal. Aber wir haben zum Beispiel auch ein Problem mit den China-IPs und China-Leuten usw. Ich wollte jetzt nur noch mal Senf dazu geben und zwar diese China-Leute.
Was für China-Leute? Wo überredest du gerade von Computerspiel-Benutzern aus China? Und was für Probleme habt ihr da? Die Leute aus China kommen nie auf die Server, weil die große Firewall immer alles blockt? Dann sag doch mal kurz den Satz.
Einfach ganz einfaches Ding. Sie benutzen verschiedene Routen, sowohl über Niederlande, über Großbritannien, über sonst welche Länder.
Ich vermute, dass dein Problem nicht wirklich ganz in die Sendung gehört. Dazu kommt, dass du nicht genau beschreiben kannst, wie es aussieht. Und wir haben nicht mehr viel Zeit, aber trotzdem vielen Dank für den Versuch. Dann haben wir noch Dominik.
Hi.
Du hattest noch mal eine Frage, wo ich dich erstmal fragen muss, ob dir so ein Thema passt. Jetzt geht es um Elena. Ist es auch Teil dieses?
Also ich bin neugierig.
Okay, stell mal deine Frage.
Ich wollte ein kurzes Update geben.
Ich war heute mit Meinart in Karlsruhe.
Dominik, du bist es. Hi.
Ja, hat er doch gesagt, der Dominik.
Okay, vier Leute verstehen Sie jetzt gerade blendend. Ich bin raus und vermutlich die ganzen, die ganzen, sagen Leute vom Radio auch. Was ist Elena? Wer ist Dominik? Was ist die News?
Dominik gehört zum Markerzensur und Dominik ist Jurist. Und Hacker im Geiste, kann man das so sagen?
Ja, ich meine.
Dominik war heute in Karlsruhe und hat die 22.000 Vollmachten für die Verfassungsbeschwerde gegen Elena beim Bundesverfassungsgericht eingekippt. Dazu kommen wir jetzt. Elena ist dieses Arbeitnehmervorratsdatenspeicherungsgesetz, wo von allen Leuten, die in Deutschland in einem Beschäftigungsverhältnis sind, Daten wie Name, Geburtsdatum, Arbeitsbeginn, Arbeitsende, Urlaubstage, Krankheit, Krankheitsgrund, Streik und so weiter abgespeichert werden an einer zentralen Stelle und in Zukunft vom Arbeitsamt bis hin zu sonst was genutzt werden sollen.
Also eine Art bundesweite Stechuhr.
Also das ist ja elektronische Entgeltennachweis. Nur noch mal um den Namen Elena zu erzählen.
Aber Dominik, wie war es denn heute in Karlsruhe?
Wir haben uns heute Morgen in ein Hotel getroffen, haben eine Pressekonferenz gemacht, sind abgeschrieben zum Verfassungsgericht.
Und jetzt ist ein Verbindung gerade ein bisschen komisch. Kannst du ruhig stehen bleiben? Genau. Und jetzt noch mal von vorn.
Wir haben uns im Hotel getroffen. Gestern Abend sind wir heute Morgen zum Verfassungsgericht gefahren, nachdem wir eine Pressekonferenz gemacht haben. Und haben anschließend die Vollmachten mit 62 Ordnern abgegeben. Und haben versucht, das Thema nochmal in die große Öffentlichkeit rein zu drücken.
Ihr müsst einen Bollerwagen dabei gehabt haben, oder?
Das war ein größerer Bollerwagen.
Wie viel 62 Aktenordner voll?
Genau, 62 Leitzordner plus noch mal 5 Leitzordner Beschwerdeschrift. Um die Kurve zu bekommen zu dem Thema, das kann ganz prima genutzt werden, um Persönlichkeitsprofile anzulegen. Also nicht im Hinblick auf Kommunikationsdaten, sondern im Hinblick auf die Frage, was kann jemandem wirtschaftlich stemmen?
Du meinst jetzt Industrie-Spionage oder was?
Darauf läuft es wohl hinaus.
Ja, okay, dass man mit Arbeitnehmerdaten hervorragende Betriebsspionage betreiben kann und auch über die Arbeitnehmer eine Menge herausfindet, das ist, glaube ich, klar, wenn man fünf Minuten darüber nachdenkt. Aber wir schweifen schon wieder vom Thema ab und haben nicht mehr viel Zeit. Gibt es noch etwas ganz Großartiges heute aus Karlsruhe zu berichten? Außer, dass die Klage jetzt eingereicht ist?
Eingereicht und alle sind gespannt.
Die nächste Verfassungsschwerde ist also am Start, ist heute abgegeben worden und die Strategie ist quasi, wir bewerfen die Leute solange mit Papier, bis sie bluten. Wir haben jetzt noch zwei Minuten quasi.
Das müssen wir noch dementieren. Das Verfassungsgericht guckt schon, wie viele Leute sich für ein Thema interessieren. Gerade bei der Vorratsentsprechung war es schon ein wichtiger Punkt, dass sich so viele Leute dafür interessiert haben, dass sie so viele Leute engagiert haben. Insofern macht sowas tatsächlich auch schon Sinn.
Na ja, bei den Netzsperren ja wohl auch. Also ohne die Petitionen von den fast 140.000 Leuten hätten wir nie erreicht, was wir erreicht haben, nämlich, dass das Gesetz nicht angewendet wird. Das ist, was wir wollten und wir haben es hingekriegt.
Aber es ist tatsächlich sozusagen aufgrund der Petition, wobei...
Aber ich denke schon, dass die Gegenöffentlichkeit und auch die sachlichen Argumente, die wir von Pontius zu Pilatus getragen haben, dazu beigetragen haben. Es ist ja jetzt noch so, dass die Unionsfraktion im Bundestag der Schrecken in den Knochen steckt über diese öffentliche Empörung.
Also spezifisch bei so einem Thema, wo sie dachten, da ist kein ernsthafter Widerstand zu erwarten.
Ja, gerade bei diesem emotionalen, ja.
Und dann ist es ganz...
Worüber werden wir in einem Jahr an dieser Stelle reden?
Tja, vermutlich immer noch über die EU. Das ist völlig unklar. Die Prozesse in der EU können sehr schnell, aber sehr langsam passieren. Wenn jetzt da das Europäische Parlament auch ein Wörtchen mitzureden hat.
Na ja, außerdem müssen Schweden bald wahlen, nicht wahr? Das sind schwedische EU-Kommissare. Schweden hat eine sehr aktive Piratenpartei. Also, hey komm, wir kriegen das auch noch.
Okay, wir hatten jetzt zwei Stunden Spaß mit Netzsperren, einem ACTA-Geheimvertrag und einem Jugend-Bedien-Schutz-Staatsvertrag. Wir werden auch noch weiter mit Spaß haben, weil die EU mit drin hängen und dadurch ist es ein bisschen länger. Jetzt noch kurz ein Tipp, wenn jemand die Sendung zugehört hat und sich weiter zu dem Thema informieren will, wo geht er hin?
Also er kann sich zum einen an den ACTA-Zensur wenden. Der hat eine sehr umfangreiche Webseite und auch eine sehr große Wiki, wo auch mittlerweile mehrsprachig alles da ist. Eine große Plattform ist auch Mogis, der Verein, der auch sehr viele Sprachen hat. Und ich glaube aber, dass man schlicht auch Google benutzen kann, denn wir haben ein Jahr über diese Netzsperren gestritten. Wir hatten auch schon mal eine Sendung dazu, wo wir auch einige technische Details genannt haben. Genau, und Guzi hat noch eine Idee.
Ja, ich wollte noch mal kurz anmerken, wegen dem Jugendmedienstaatsvertrag, da gibt es eine Petition.
Genau.
Also es gibt 16 Petitionen, nämlich für jedes Bundesland eine. Man nehme Stift und Block und so bereit oder einfach mal eine Tastatur. Die Adresse lautet, ich diktiere. Http://www.zensur-in.de Da findet ihr alles andere. Das ist nicht von uns, aber ich finde, man sollte es mal sagen. Da will jemand irgendwie in 16 Landesparlamenten Petitionen einbringen. Also wenn ihr da mitmachen wollt und gegenseit unterschreiben könnt, dann helft dir da bestimmt, dass es nochmal auf die politische Agenda der Landtage kommt.
Da wisst ihr jetzt also wo es geht. Falls ihr die URL nicht genau verstanden habt, vielleicht trägt sie ja noch jemand ins Wiki ein. Hint, Hint, Hint.
Einverstanden.
Oder ihr guckt einfach nach dem Podcast, den gibt es in wenigen Stunden, auf fritz.de und dann bestimmt auch im Laufe der Woche auf chaosradio.de. Vielen Dank euch für sie gewesen sein.
Na, bitteschön.
Gerne doch.
Es war auch sehr schön, dass ihr zu früh gekommen seid.
Ich bringe noch nächstes Mal eine Mate mit.
Hey, das ist cool. Als nächstes kommen hier Smith und Smart. Und ich glaube, der Herr Smart hat eine neue Frisur, was ich ganz ungewöhnlich finde.
Der hat Gesichtshahre.
Na, der wird sich wahrscheinlich auch gleich auf eine längere Diskussion mit einer hier anwesenden Frau einlassen müssen. Das, was ich jetzt nicht näher kommentieren will. Ich sage vielen Dank euch auch fürs Zuhören und Mitmachen. Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß im weiteren Verlauf der Nacht und sage bis zum nächsten Mal. Und macht immer schön eure Backups und lasst euch nicht überwachen.
Don't forget I'm in your extended network.